ماذا يفقد الإنسان عندما يفقد عربيِّته طيب؟
اللُّغة العربية
هويته، يا أخي أنت كيف تتواصل مع عالمك الدَّاخلي؟
أنت قاعد تتكلم على مصالح...
أنت كم سنة تتوظف في حياتك؟
كم سنة تشتغل في حياتك؟
اللي يؤسس لهذا كله أساسًا تواصلك الداخلي مع نفسك
مع أفكارك العُليا، ومع الوجود
بأي لغة يتم هذا؟
بالإنقليزي عادي
ماشي إذا أنت...
لا، عمرها ما راح تكون بنفس الجودة
لا، إذا افترضت أني أنا تربيت كلُغة أُم
ما في مشكلة تفقد اتصالك بثُراثك الحضاري
أهلًا هذا فنجان من ثمانية، وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
البخاري أكلة سعودية رغم أن اسمها يُنسب إلى بُخارى
والفول، والتَّميس أكلة سعودية
والكبسة سعودية
رغم أنَّ الرز هندي أو أمريكي
والدجاج برازيلي، والبهارات هندية
ليش أقدر أقول أن كل هذه سعودية الهوية؟
لأنها كبقية الأشياء اللي أخذناها من بقيَّة ثقافات العالم
وطوَّرناها بما يتناسب مع حاجاتنا وثقافتنا
وأصبحت شكلًا جديدًا لا يشبه أصلها
هذه حلقة عن هوية الأشياء
لكن، ماذا عن الأشياء اللي هي من أصل ثقافتنا؟
احنا من قدَّمها للعالم كُله، كالقهوة
القهوة جزء مهم من هويتنا كسعوديين، وعرب
نُعرِّف فيها الكرم والضِّيافة
لها شروط شديدة الحدِّية بطريقة تحضيرها وتقديمها
ودِّي أعرف ليه صارت كذا؟
ماذا يعني فنجان الهيف والضيف والكيف
كيف تكونت العادات الاجتماعية والثقافيَّة
حول القهوة في الجزيرة العربية
العام الماضي أعلنت وزارة الثقافة السعودية
أنَّ عام 2022 هو عام القهوة السعودية
وحصل الجدل الواسع هل يحق للسعودية
أن تقول أن هذه قهوة سعودية؟
هل المقصود فيها البُن؟
فالسعودية تزرع البُن في جيزان وعسير والباحة وغيرها
إذا المقصود طريقة تحضيرها
فالسعودية كذلك هي أكبر بقعة جغرافية تقدم القهوة بهذه الطريقة
صحيح أن فيه طرائق مختلفة
لكن في الأخير هذه كلها سعودية، وهي عربية كذلك
وما أدري ليه تصير حساسيَّة من القهوة السعودية
ولا تصير لما تقول: القهوة الأمريكية أو القهوة التُّركية
ضَيفي في هذه الحلقة الباحث في هوية الأشياء
ومؤلف ديوان القهوة، ماجد الأهدل
يُجيب عن التساؤلات اللي قبل شوي
ويؤكد أنَّ العرب هم من اكتشفوا القهوة للعالم
وهم أوَّل من أضافوا السكر عليها
وأول من أضافوا الحليب
وأوَّل من شربها حارَّة، وباردة
فقد عرف أجدادنا اللَّاتيه، والكولد برو
قبل أن يعرف العالم شيئًا اسمه القهوة
قبل أن نبدأ شاركونا أسماء ضيوف أو مواضيع تقترحونها
على بريد البرنامج finjan@Thamanyah.com
أمَّا الآن لنبدأ
يا أخي دُوبي أناقشه على الكتابة العثمانيَّة
فاسم «طاها»
فهو يُكتب «طَه»
الرسم العثماني تقصد؟
الرسم العثماني
ليش يقول رسم ما هو كتابة؟
الرَّسم لأنه هو الخط
الرَّسم اسم عام لكل ما ينتج عن عمليَّة حركة اليد
فيجوز أنِّي أقول كتابة أو رسم؟
إيه، الكتابة العثمانيَّة
لكن الرَّسم لأنه اصطلاح، مصطلح الرَّسم فـ...
عشان لا يشتبك مع اللغة العثمانيَّة...
فهو الرسم العثماني؟
نعم
فهو «طه»
«طه»
«عبدالرحمن» ؟
«عبدالرحمن»
«القسم» و«الحرث» بدلًا من «الحارث» و«القاسم»
لكن، «الحارث»
الآن تكتب «الحارث» بالألف
بس «عبدالرحمن» بقيت، ما أكتب الألف باسمي أبدًا
و«طه» ما أعتقد أن أحد يكتبها بالألف
صحيح
فأيش اللي يخليها كذا؟
مرَّة تستمر على الرَّسم العثماني
ومرَّات تخرج عن الرَّسم العثماني، وترجع صحيحة
هل يجوز أقول أنها صحيحة؟
اللي هي الكتابة العاديَّة؟
هي صحيحة
هذه الصح؟
شوف هو ما في صح، الاستعمال راح على أيش؟
لأن ترى فيه مدرستين في الإملاء
وكان فيه أكثر من مدرسة، لكن فيه مدرستين
في المدرسة اللي هي أنك تكتب ما تنطق
وكان عليها الشيخ «حمد الجاسر»
كان يكتب «ليلا» و«موسيقا» بالـ...
يقول لك ما فيه فرق بين الممدودة، والمقصورة
في ناس يقول لك أثبت ما تنطق، كالكتابة العروضية
الأصوات كلها تُكتب
الشدة تُكتب...
مثلًا تجي تقول...
«سماؤن» تثبت النون
لكن هذه كتابة عروضية
الغرض منها أنك تُقطِّع البيت الشِّعري
عشان تعرف التَّفعيلات هذه تنتمي لأي بحر؟
لكن الرَّسم القرآني، هذا اللي مُتوارث. وإن حصل له تطوير
اللي احنا قاعدين نمشي عليه هذا حصل له تطوير آخر ستين سنة
لكن تجي ترجع للمخطوطة بالمصحف القديم، نعم ما تثبت
ليش؟ يا أخي أسرع
الخفَّة، لأن تعرف عندك نُدرة ورق وحبر
ثم خلاص فيه نوع من الاصطلاح
يعني لو اصطلحنا اليوم على أنه «عبدالرحمن» بدون ألف
إذًا هي «عبدالرحمن» بدون ألف
دام أنا، وأنت وصلنا إلى نفس النتيجة
«عبدالرحمن» تُنطق «عبدالرحمان» كلّنا ننطقها بنفس النطق
فما فيه إشكال، لا مُشاحة في الرسم؟
إلّا
لا، ما أحد يقول «عبدالرحمن» إلى الآن
صحيح، بس إذا أنا صرت أكتب بأي طريقة إملائيَّة
فإذا اصطلحنا اليوم أنا، وأنت
أنت وقوَّتك
إي عادي، أكتب أنت وقوَّتك
ليش ما تلاحظ مثلًا يكتب «إلي»
هذه المدرسة المصرية في الإملاء
ولمَ، يعني ليش صار مقبول هذا؟
مو بـ«إلي»...
«إلي» و«علي»
أكتب «على» ولّا «علي»؟
فيه فرق بين الأثنتين؟
هي المدرسة اللي أنت قاعد تأخدها
بعدما صار عندك مناهج، وقواعد مُقننة
قبلها كان الموضوع على شُيوع الاستخدام
قبل دخول الطابعة كانت الفكرة أنه أنا أُفرِّق بين هذه وهذه
أيش الأكثر الياء ولّا المقصورات؟
الأكثر الياء في الكلام في الرسم
فأنا أقول لك اختصارًا، اللي ما فيها حط لها نقاط
لأنه أقل «إلى» و«على» أقل
لكن اللي فيها ياءات كثير، كثيرة في الكلام
فبدل ما أنا أقعد أنقُط كل كلمة فيها ياء؛ أحذفها
صار عندنا هذه مدرسة في الإملاء
لما صار الموضوع أبسط ولا تحتاج لحِبر، ولا غيره
ولكن نعود إلى المدرسة الأصلية، أن المقصورة، مقصورة بدون
والياء تحتها نقطتان
نقطتين في الأسفل والفاء نقطة أو بدون نقطة
كلها اصطلاحات أقوام. لما صار عندنا الآن معيارية إلى حدٍّ ما
ارتضت كل دولة أن خلاص أن هذا أفضل
أيش فكرة الكتابة أصلًا، والكلام؟
تسهيل التَّواصل
إذا ما أعطاني هذا الغرض، فعندي إشكالية في نظرية الاتصال
فأنت تقول أنه ممكن أن يكون المصريين يكتبون «إلي» و«علي»
«إلي» المطار، هو لأنه مثلًا يمكن زمان كانت طباعة
أنها تكون على حديد فقالوا: ما نطبع أحرف زيادة؟
صحيح
وقبلها كان النُّساخ حذفوا كل حروف الزِّيادة
«الحرث» و«القسم» حذفوها طلبًا للاختصار
بس على نقطة التواصل...
اللي احنا نتفق عليه الهدف من اللغة هو أيش؟ التواصل
الهدف الأساسي، نعم
بس هذه السيولة مرة أحس أنك تقوله
بس بكرة لو شفت واحد كتب لكن، وحط لام وألف وكاف ونون
بتزعل، أنت زعلان؟
أنا راح أقولها
أنت راح تقولها
طيب؟
ليش؟
خلاص هو وصل لك الفكرة إنه قال لك...
يا سلام
زي مثلًا أنت ما تقدر تحضر مجلس
أو اجتماع في مجلس الوزراء، وأنت لابس بدلة رياضة
يعني لكل مقام لغته وهيئته
لأن اللي يمثلك أيش أنت؟
أنا مثلًا ما أعرفك، ما يمثلك إلا مظهرك، وصورتك
واللي يمثل داخلك وأفكارك
طريقة كلامك ولغتك أو مكتوبك إذا كنت غائبًا عني
هذا لازم...
ماشي أنا راح أفهمك
راح أفهمك لو جئت تكلمت معاي بعاميَّة ولّا حتى بلهجة، راح أفهمك
لكن ما راح يفهمك إنسان آخر من منطقة، وعينة لهجيَّة، ولغوية مختلفة
فلازم فيه معياريَّة، المعياريَّة لابد منها
حتى المعياريَّة قد تختلف في بعض المناحي
فتلاقي أن جهود اللغويين توجه إلى أن نتواضع على شيء
ونصطلح على شيء؛ لأن تبغى تخدم...
أن هذا القُمع يخدم مساحة واسعة جدًّا من الناس
فالدَّعوة للعامية دعوة باطلة
لأنها تقوِّض أساس فكرة التواصل اللغوي
أنه يا أخي ما راح يفهموني الناس اللي برى
أنا فكرتي محليَّة
يا أخي ما تقدر تحكم فكرتك محليَّة، ولّا عالميَّة
فكرة إنسانيَّة، مُشترك إنساني عام، لذلك وُجدت ترجمة
خلاص أنا أكتب لغة معياريَّة معينة
حتى يُخدم هذا النَّص بعدَة اتجاهات
تقدر تُأوّله صحيح، وتقدر تترجمه بشكل جيد
تقدر تدرِّسه، وتقدر تستخرج منه أفكار، ترفع الـ...
ما هو موضوعنا بس جميل الموضوع
إي أنا أذكر ما هو موضوعنا
جميل
أنا موضوعي...
تعرف أن كان تخصُّصي لغة؟
لا. أعرف أن تخصصك هندسة
كنت قبلها لغة
قبلها لغة؟
أي، كنت قبلها لغة...
أنا بقول لك أيش تخصصي؟
أنا تخصصي أن أُبقي فنجان سواليف
لطالما أنا أُدير الحوار، وأنت حاول تبقى معي...
على أنَّك تخليه سواليف
حاضر، أبشر
لا، بس تلقاه في تويتر قصدي
أبغى أفهم الكتب. بس تلقى في تويتر أنه عادي
وأحيانًا الناس تزعل، وأحيانًا ما تزعل
فهل يبقى هذا حتى لنطاق التواصل
لطالما أني أرسلت لك رسالة مليانة أخطاء إملائيّة
وصلتك الفكرة يا سلام
هذا الكلام اللي تقوله؟
هذا مو مسألة لغويَّة
اللي أنت قاعد تقوله: أنت يا أخي ليش تزعل؟
هو الآن لما أنت تغلط، هو ما قاعد يُحاكمك...
يُحاكمك على ما استقر عنده من الصَّواب اللُّغوي
شوف، هذا الخلاف العالي في اللغة
هل نكتبها بمقصورة، ولّا بممدودة؟
هذه من مسائل الخلاف العالي
هل يستلزم هذا النطق، وهذا الرسم ولّا ما يستلزم؟
هذه المسائل اللي اختلف فيها «أبن دريد»
واختلف فيها «الكسَّائي» و«الفرَّاء»
ومن بعدهم من جاء من اللَّغويين والإملائيِّين كذلك
إلى الآن فيه مشاكل في الإملاء ما حُلَّت
لكن قال لك يا عمي دامها شغاله، دام تمشي مشيها...
ماشي، فما أحتاج
لكن يجي واحد، أنت تكتب «لاكن» بيجي يستدرك عليك
هو ما يُلام على هذا
هذا اللي استقر عنده من الصواب اللغوي، ثم...
يا أخي احنا ماشيين في تيَّار
أنا بدأت أؤمن بهذا النوع...
يا أخي ساير الناس في هذه الأمور
سايرهم، دامه فاهمك بالصيغتين
وهذه نسبة الخطأ فيها أعلى في نظره خلِّيها في صيغته
وشكرًا أنتم تنازلتم عن الكاف الـ...
المعقودة؟
الكاف الفارسية
والله يعني...
لغويًّا صح، هذه من اللِّسانيين
لمَّا يكتبوا لك مصطلح في كتب اللِّسانيات، وللا كتب الصوتيَّات
يجيبها كذا عشان أنت كلساني تفهمني
أنا ما أقصد هذه، ولّا هذه فيحط لها صورة معينة
الناس هذه عنده كاف فوقها خط
وما أعرف ليش الخط؟
صوت القِيف
هي مشكلة
أتذكر كذا أنه نكتب مصطلحات أجنبية، وأسماء أعجمية
مثلًا تكتب أي اسم ما تدري أنت كقارئ عربي كيف يُنطق
أنت ما تقدر تعرف، ما تدري إذا هو أنا أقصد أنه جيم، ولّا قاف
فتلقى فيه ناس حتى «قلقامش» يقول لك «جلجامش» وعادي
وتلقى مثلًا «غاليليو» يقول لك «جاليليو» فليش؟
لأنه قرأها جيم وزي «الجرابوكس»
«جوتا»
«قير بوكس» صارت «الجرابوكس»، روح يا وحش
الشيخ «محمد ناصر العُبود» رحمة الله عليه
عنده معجم الكلمات الدَّخيلة
وعنده معجم كلمات قَضت
لو تجي تجرد هذا المعجم
تجد أن كثير من معجمنا اليَومِي دخيل
معجمنا اليومي معظمه...
يعني اليوم موسم شتاء، أيش أشهر فعالية تصير في الشتاء؟
كَشتَة؟
فارسية
بَخشَة، كمزروع فارسيَّة
كثير من الكلام تركي أو فارسي، لكن وجد طريقه في يومك
وزي ما فعلت العرب قديمًا
وإنقليزي حتى الحين
«الجرابوكس» مثلًا بس أيش اللي حصل؟
زي من يجي يقول لك يا عمي اللفظ الأعجمي أُنطقه
اللي يسلك مع جهازك هو الصَّح، نُقطة
أي، عرِّبه «قير بوكس» احنا ما عندنا هذا الصوت بهذه التقاطيع
«جرابوكس»
فتلاقي أنه مثلًا الشَّمبر أو الميكانيكا
الميكانيكا من أكبر...
طبعًا يسمُّوها اللغات المخصوصة
اللغات الخاصة لأن تجد أنَّ لها معجم خاص يعرفوه أهل الـ...
يعني الكهربائي «الذكر» و«الأنثى»  بالنسبة له مفهوم ثاني
مفهوم بعيد عن «الذكر» و«الأنثى» للمفهوم العام المشترك
الإنسان عنده الطَّبَّة، والقياسات
«الكوع» في شفت مرَّة كذا صورة
أنت لو رحت عند محل أدوات صحية ترى هذه لها أسماء تجارية
أنت تروح لا تسميها الاسم الهندسي
واللي غالبًا ما راح تعرفه
لها اسم «كوع» وفيه «أبو خشم» وفيه أبو مدري أيش
هو هذه أسماء السوق عشان تدخل...
السماحيَّة للدخول في مجموعات لغوية أكثر؛ أنك لازم تكون مثقف لُغويًّا
تلاقي هذا الإنسان المثقف اللغوي
ذكاؤه الاجتماعي عالي، وذكاؤه العاطفي عالي
يعرف يدير المواقف لأن ذكاءه اللغوي عالي
فما يقع في مشاكل مع مجموعات أخرى
تلاقيه مثلًا مع المغاربة ينتقي كلامه
لأنه يعرف أنه مثلًا في بعضها مُحيّدة عن معناها
مُجيّرة إلى معنى آخر أو الاستخدام...
معنى المعجم الجميع يتَّفق عليه
لكن المعنى الاستخدامي التَّداولي فيه إشكال
صحيح
طيب، ودِّي أعرف الحين دامك دخلت أحس في مدخل رائع
اللي هو كيف تعاملوا العرب مع المفردات الدَّخلية؟
أو حتى في تعريبهم للأشياء الجديدة؟
دائمًا أقول كيف وصلوا إلى أنهم مثلًا...
أنهم يسمُّوا مثلًا دول بهذه الأسماء؟
كيف قالوا ألمانيا؟
ولِمَ؟ يعني لا هي بالإنقليزي، ولا بالألماني تعطي هذا الاسم
فكيف تعاملوا مع المفردات الدَّخيلة أو هُم كيف...؟
هو قبل كان العربي لا يحتاج إلى تسمية إلَّا إذا اضطر عليها
إذا اضطر على هذه التَّسمية سمَّى
معظم الأسماء الدَّخيلة، والمُعرَّبة
هي أسماء لأدوات ما كانت موجودة عند العرب
فواكه ما تُزرع في أرضهم، وخضار ما هي موجودة في أرضهم
آلات مثل الطَّيلسان والصَّولجان والأتاريك والأباريق
هذه ما كانوا يعرفونها ولا يصنعونها
لمَّا دخلت
الجورب مثلًا المعظم يظن أنها عربيَة، هي معربة
وجورب هي أصلًا كُورْبَة أو كَورَبَة من الفارسيَّة
وربَّما دخلت لهم من ثقافة أخرى كان يُرتدى فيها الجوارب
ثم دخلت العربيَّة قالت: الجَورَبة
الكورَبة هذه أو الكورْبة...
الجَورَبة خلاص «فَوْعَل»
دخلت في جهازي الصوتي، وأُصيغها وبهذه الطريقة فعمّت
«النارنج» اللي هو «الأورنج»
احنا أعطينا للغربيين «النَّارِنج » سموه «أورنج»
واحنا أخدنا البرتقال اللي هو أجنبي
عملية تَقارُض ثقافي جميلة حصلت بيننا
العرب كانوا طبعًا...
النَّارِنج من الحمضيات
عرفوه العرب بالنَّارِنج، راح لأوربا باسم أورانج
وجاءنا من عندهم باسم برتقال، لأنه جاء من البرتغال
وسميِّنا المندرين «يوسف أفندي»
نسبةً لبعثة، ابتعث «محمد علي باشا» أو من جاء بعده
ابتُعث ناس إلى مالطا وفرنسا
فكان منهم هذا الرجل «يوسف أفندي»
وهو أول من استزرعه في حديقة الخديوي، كما يبدو لي؛ فسُميَّت باسمه
تجد أنه عادي مرنين في التعامل مع المُعرَِّب
وطبعًا يُفرقون بين الدخيل والمعرب والمترجم
المعرب اللي تغير صوته
أني أنا أخذت الكلمة كما هي، ما ترجمتها
أني أخذتها عرَّبتها مثلًا الجورب، هذه مُعرَّبة، أصلها دخيل، نعم
طبعًا فيه هذه الإشكالية أنه بعضهم يقول لك المعرَّب والدَّخيل واحد
وبعضهم يقول لك لا، نفرّق بين الدَّخيل والمعرَّب
الشيء اللي دخل صوتًا، وبقي كما هو، دخيل
المعرب ما طرأ عليه نوع من التَّعديل، والتكييف
على مقتضى أصوات العرب اللي ينطقون بها يُفرِّقون
وطبعًا حصل الخلاف هل في القرآن دخيل؟
هل في القرآن معرّب؟ إلى آخره
فالفريقان يختصمان في الموضوع
على وفق نظرية أنه التَّقارض بين لغات حية موجودة في نفس الأطار
في ناس تقول لك لا
كل هذه اللغات اللي أخذ منها القرآن تعود إلى أصل عربي واحد
اللغة العربية الأم
فبهذا الاعتبار لا يعتبر هناك دخيل ولا يعتبر هناك معرب
طبعًا هي نظرتين بس مستويين من النظر في هذه القضيَّة
وليش اليوم احنا نشوف فيه تحدي؟
أو دفاع عن دخول أي مصطلحات جديدة للغة العربية
فتلقى فيه هذه الحدَّة مقابل اللغة الإنقليزية
فأي كلمة إنقليزية تدخل
لما أقول لك مثلًا: «كُول»
أو أي كلمة
فتُأخذ بأن المفترض أن نِجيب الكلمة العربية اللي مُقابلها
«كيوت»
شوف العرب كانوا ببساطة اللي ما هو...
هل كان عندهم هذه الحدِّية في دخول الكلمات؟
وهل هذا صحي للغة ولّا لا، اللي احنا نسويه اليوم؟
راح أتكلم عن رأيي، لأن الموضوع مرَّة حساس
قديمًا اللي كان يدخل، ويسمح له الدخول
هو ما لا يوجد له مقابل
يجي باسمه، غرض غير موجودة غي ثقافتي يجي باسمه
وأبقيه على ما هو عليه
أو أني أستعير له شيء أقرب، أستعير له اسم
اليوم اللي قاعد يحصل أنك تجد أن فيه شيء ترفي
له مقابلات بل له مفردات كثيرة
مسألة الاستخدام شيء ثاني يخضع لقضية ربما لا تكون لغويَة
قضية ثقافية أو نفسية أو اعتياد وأُلف
تعيده لأًطر معقولة، وتقول له:
ترى يا أخي تكرارك لاستخدام هذه القضية
ربما يضعف من مرونة معجمك العربي
اللي هو مرتبط بشكل عضوي مع ثقافتك وأفكارك وحيوية...
أنه يستجيب أو ما يستجيب هذه تحتاج وقت، وغير مُلزِمة
لكن صوابيَّة الفكرة نعم الأفضل أنك تستخدم العربي
ليش؟ جدّد المعجم
واحد يقول لك يا أخي المعجم مستواه مُتعالي عن التداولية
يا أخي احنا اليوم ممكن نستخدم
فقط في اليوم كله 500 كلمة
بينما المعجم مليء بالكلام
طيب، ما اضطررنا إليه
هذا المستوى التداول اللي قدرنا نتعامل فيه
ماني قاعد أشرح فكرة أنا قاعد أتكلم، وقاعد أطلب من مطعم
مو ضروري أن أستخدم معجمي كامل
ولو استخدمت ربما معجمي ما أوصلت الفكرة
فتجي تلاقي أنت تبغى تكون متوازن بين أن توصل الفكرة
وبين أن أمثل ثقافتي وهويتي
وبين أني ما وجدت مثلًا مرادف
وبعضهم يقول يا أخي وصلتني هكذا
مسألة أني أبحث هذه مسألة تعتمد على اجتهادك، وعلى جهدك
وتحتاج إلى مبادرات، وتحتاج إلى سياسة لغويَّة للبلد
يعني مسألة...
أنت راح تقوم بدور، كشخص وكفرد، لابد أن تقوم بدورك بالحد الأدنى
وفيه دور آخر، المجتمع ينظم نفسه تحت هذه المظلة
أن أنا ثقافتي ثقافة لغوية
الحامي الأول للثقافة هي اللغة، بلا شك هذه النقطة لا يُختلف عليها
وفي دور الدولة، أنه يجب أن تقنن سياسات معينة
ليش ما يسمح في الوزارات أن لغة التخاطب ما تكون بغير العربية؟
يحتاج أن أنت...
يعني نوع من السيادة، السيادة اللغوية
نوع من السيادة السياسية، السيادة الثقافيَّة
والسيادة اللغوية، هي نوع من السيادة ويُحترم
هذا السؤال الأول، السؤال الثاني؟
فأنا أقول لك أن فيه هذه الحديَّة
فأنت قبل شوي تقول على النطاق الفردي، لك دور
أيش الدور؟
فهو مفترض أن طالما احنا
جالسين نتكلم، خليني أتكلم بالدَّارج، والسهل
واللي أنا أفهمه، وأنت تفهمه وعادي
اليوم أنا لو أقول لهم «قروب واتساب»
بتقول لي شوف اللي أرسلته في القروب اليوم عادي، وهي كلمة «إنجليزية»
هي ممكن تكون مؤشر بسيط
لكن ما هو هذا اللي الناس أعتقد أن عندهم حديَّة معاه
«قروب» وللا غيره هذه أمور بسيطة
الناس تتكلم على أن وأنت تستخدم كلمة «قروب»
فاعلم أن هي ما هي الأصل
كيف؟
اعلم أن هي ما هي الأصل، وتقدر تقول «مجموعة»
فيه بديل لها بالعربي، بس أنه غير مستخدم
يا سلام عليك، ما فيه إشكال
طيب يجيك واحد يقول لك خلاص نستسلم للقدر وما نستخدمها
ما هي مستخدمة
ما هو اللي خلاها ما هي مستخدمة؟
نوع من الرواج حصل لكلمة أخرى
يُقابله نوع من الرواج لكلمة أخرى
لكن لمَّا ما عندي سياسة لغوية
أسيب الموضوع وعاء ثقافي كبير، والأخلاط فيه تتصارع
واللي يفوز خلاص، بكرة أجي أقول: والله، لغة الناس 60% منها دخيلة
في بعض المواطن راح تلاقي أن 60% من لغتك دخيلة
إذا دخلت اجتماعات وكذا
أنت راح تضطر إلى أن تستخدم في مجال عملك، بلا شك
لكن أنت تؤطر هذا تحت إطار المصلحة
أنه الآن الأصلح لهذا النطاق الأفضل
أيش المرحلة اللي قبلها؟ طيب أنا هذا ما هو عاجبني
لا، أنت الآن في مسألة ما هي لغوية
مسألة معيشية، أنت قاعد تعيش وتشتغل
ادرس وتعلَّم، وترجم، وخلِّيك أفضل ما يمكن في أي لغة ثانية
مع إقرارك...
لأن هذا أنت ما تقدر تصلحه كفرد
هذه مشكلة مجامع علمية، مشكلة سياسات لغوية لدولة
حركة التعريب، حركة التأليف في مسألة اللغة
وأساسًا حركة دراسة واقع اللغة المُعاشة، ما هو حاصل
فيجيك الواحد يتحمل حمل الأمة كله على نفسه
ويقول لك يا عم الدنيا قاعدة تفُك منِّي
أنت على مستوى شخصي خلِّيك آمن أنَّ لغتك هي رسولك إلى تراثك
ما راح تستطيع فهم تراثك وتقافتك، وتراث المنطقة، حتى المحكي
ما راح تفهمه بدون لغة مؤسسة، لأن هذا إفراز للغتك القديمة
لكن برضو لا تحتقن
لا تشعر أن هذه نهاية العالم
لأنه ما هو من دورك، أنت اللي مسؤول عنه
خاصة نفسك في هذا الموضوع
استطعت أنه تنقل هذه الفكرة
وتجعلها أكثر سواغيَّة ومقبوليَّة عند الناس
فبها ونعمت، وجزاك الله ألف خير، شيء جميل
لكن لا تحتقن زيادة، وتقعد تصارع طواحين الهواء، والناس...
يا أخي فيه تفوّق للغات الأجنبية، لا يُنكر
تفوق علمي
90% من لغة العلم اليوم في العالم إنقليزي
بل أن كثيرًا من الفرنسيين يدعون...
فيه عالم لِسَانيَّات جزائري اسمه «رشيد عيسى»
كان يقول للمغاربة بشكل عام يا جماعة الخير
إن كنتم لابد فاعلين أن تلتصقوا بلغة أجنبية فالتصقوا بالإنقليزية
فكُّونا من الفرنسية صعبة وغثيثة
وغير كذا قاعدة تطيل أمد الاستعمار الناعم لبلدانكم
اقطعوا صلتكم بها لأنه علميًّا ما راح تنفعكم
90% مما يُنشر علميًّا في العالم باللغة الإنقليزية
ما نرجع للعربية لأن المسألة، صح...
فلو قال عربي بهذا الكلام؟
هو غير واقعي
هذا وارد
هو لازم يصير في يوم من الأيام
لكن ما هو اللي تقدر تطبقه في مدى بسيط، وارد ويمكن
وهذا اللي يؤمن به كل إنسان يؤمن ومسلم
لأن العربي يؤمن بهذه لكن...
يؤمن بأن العربي مهم
بس أنا أقصد أن اليوم اللي جالس يحصل
أنك تلقى الناس يهتمون للغة الإنقليزية
ويقول لك نفس كلام الرجل الفرنسي ذا
أنه إن كان ولا بد، فخلك في الإنقليزية أفضل، لأنها هي لغة العلم
برقماتي، هي لغة العلم، وهي لغة التواصل العامة
وهي اللغة اللي تخليك تشعر
ماذا يفقد الإنسان عندما يفقد عربيَّته؟ اللغة العربية
هويته
يا أخي أنت كيف تتواصل مع عالمك الدَّاخلي؟
أنت قاعد تتكلم على مصالح...
أنت كم سنة تتوظف في حياتك؟
كم سنة تشتغل في حياتك؟
اللي يؤسس لهذا كله أساسًا تواصلك الداخلي مع نفسك
مع أفكارك العليا، ومع الوجود بأي لغة يتم هذا؟
بالإنقليزي عادي
أقدر أتواصل
ما شيء إذا أنت...
لا، عمرها ما راح تكون بنفس الجودة
لا، إذا افترضت أني أنا تربيت كلُغة أُم
ما في مشكلة، تفقد اتصالك بتراثك الحضاري
يعني ما تستطيع فهم القرآن، والمدونات الأدبية بالكامل
التاريخيَّة بالكامل، واتصالك مع نفسك
تمر عليك الأسماء، تتعلم كل اسم يمر عليك
كل اسم في كل سطر يمر عليك تتعلمه
لأن عقلك اللغوي لو كان مؤسس على اللغة العربية
ستفهم من نظرية الاشتقاق
وأنه كثير من الأمور إما أنها تأخذ اسمها من ملابسة الحال
أنها تأخذ اسمها من فعل من الأفعال
لأنه أنت خلاص عقلك اللغوي مثلًا...
تعرف أن المصدر ممكن يُشتق إلى عشرة أسماء
كلها تعني معنى وزمان مختلف
«درس» مصدر. و«مدرسة» مكان
«مدرس» فاعل. «مُدرَّس» مفعول به. «مِدراس»
إلى آخره
هذا عقلك اللغوي لأنه...
شوف احنا ما نشوف أنه هذه القضية إعجازية اليوم
لأنه احنا خلاص هي مغموسة
لكن كلمة واحدة أستطيع أني أشتق منها
لما عقلك يستبطن في هذه العملية
وتصير هي عملية بدهية بالنسبة لك
تصير عليك قراءة الـ...
طبعًا هذا مثال جدًّا سخيف، وبسيط
لكن اتصالك الحضاري بأمتك وإحساسك بإشكالاتها
التواصل مع المدونات الكبرى
احنا وحدة من مشكلاتنا اليوم، التاريخيَّة كذلك
وهذه اللي عانيت منها في معظم أبحاثي
المدوِّنة التاريخيَّة في أفق، في مستوى، والواقع في أفق
لا على مستوى أسماء، لا على مستوى أحداث، لا على مستوى...
تجي تقرأ السيرة النبوية لـ «ابن هشام»
هذا يتكلم عن عالم كأنه ما هو في السعودية، عالم ثاني
تجي تتكلم عن مناطق خُروج النَّبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
من بيته لما بلغ «الحَزَوّرة»
التفت إلى البيت، وقال: والله أنك لأحبُّ بلاد الله إلى الله
ولولا أنِّي أُخرجت منك ما خرجت
فين الحزوَّرة هذه؟
في السَّاحة بين الحرم وبين شركة مكة
فهذا موقع تاريخي، أنا الآن قرأت الحديث، وهذا الخبر في السِّيرة
ودِّي أشعر بـ...
هذا وأنت تتكلم وأنت في مكة، ومن هنا. ما وقفت عليه
أنك تجي تمشي طريق الهجرة تلاقي كثير من الأسماء غُيِّرت
مكة وشعابها وجبالها وإلى آخره
أنا لما أجي أقرأ السيرة راح تمر علي معالم كثير جغرافية
وتاريخيَّة وأسماء قبائل
لما صار الفَصل من القرن العاشر تغيرت معظم ألقاب القبائل
اختفت تكتلات قبليَّة معينة
وذابت في تحالفات أخرى، وظهرت أسماء جديدة
هذا عمل لي فصل
عمل لي فصل من المدوَّنة
خلاص الواقع شيء، والموجود في المدونة شيء
تقرأ هَوازِن، مين هَوازِن؟
ما في قبيلة اسمها هَوازِن
اللي موجودين هم اللي كانوا في الحجاز فقط
هُذيل وقُريش وسُليم وجهينة ومزينة
ما زال من بني عدوان هذول الموجودين
القبائل الثَّانية...
الحركة اللي حصلت من القرن الخامس إلى العاشر الهجري
ما أحد يعرف أيش قاعد يصير في وسط الجزيرة العربية
تكتُّلات وتحالفات وتحوُّرات. اختفت أسماء، وظهرت أسماء
فين؟ إذا ما كان عندي عملية توثيق، وتأريخ مستمرة
مضنية ومرهقة ومملة، بس لابد تصير
لأن أنا أريد أني أرجع
أرجع أؤرِّخ لمنطقة أقول لك، لا والله حصل كذا
وهذه لا يستهان بها ترى، تعمل مُشكلات جدًّا كبيرة
فالحاصل، لما حصل الفصل
فالمُدوِّنة التاريخيَّة مفصولة عن الواقع
صرنا نعيش في طبقة بين البين
ما نعرف احنا...
حرفيًّا تقرأ التراث كأنك تقرأ تمرين عقلي لا أكثر
شيء جميل لطيف لكن ما نستخدمه في حياتنا اليومية
لذلك كأنك يعني...
كأنه الواحد قاعد يسوي عمل عقلي رائع وهو يقرأ قصيدة جاهلية
أنت المفروض أن تمر عليك هذه الأسماء
إلى حدٍ كبير لو احنا أبقينا على هذه التَّسميات، وجميلة بالمناسبة
ما كُنا راح نشعر أنها ثقيلة على النفس، وما تنحفظ
لأنه حفظنا أسماء أشرس منها على المستوى الصَّوتي
أسماء القهوة على سبيل المثال
ما يمكن أنت من أول مرة تلقطها صح
إلا إن كان ذكائك اللغوي عالي جدًّا
مع ذلك دخلت في الأُلف والعادة، وصارت بَدَهيَّة
وصرت تَعجَب من إنسان يقترح عليك اسم عربي
يا أخي فيه وعورة، وفيه وحشية، مو ضرورة
في مسألة الأُلف بس ما أنت عارف
صحيح
ومن الأشياء، أحس اللي عرَّب «موبايل» يا أخي هذا رائع
كذا الجوال، مرَّة رهيب يا أخي والله جوال لأنك تجول فيه
مع أنه ما يَعني...
يعني جوال...
فعلًا تجي تفكر فيها
أقول الهاتف الجوال، لأن فيه الهاتف الثابت
يا سلام
مرَّة رهيب يا أخي والله أنه...
واسم دَرج، لما أقول لك أعطيني رقم جوَّالك، وكم جوَّالك
يا أخي اسم حلو، حتى الآلة الحاسبة اسم مُعقَّد ترى
آلة حاسبة
بس برضو يعني...
«كالكوليتر» أعقد منَّه
إي بس الناس ما تشوفه...
الحاسبة
شوف بشكل عام، العقل اللغوي العربي يميل إلى الاختصار
في القرآن «وَاسْأَلِ الْقَرِيَةَ»
لو جاءك واحد عقله مُتعَاجم، كيف يسأل القرية؟
كيف يجي واحد عند قرية، جماد، ويسأل القرية؟
واسأل أهل القرية، هذا مجاز عقلي
خلاص، اختصارًا. واسأل القرية، أي اسأل أهل القرية
فاللغة العربية قائمة على الحذف...
أنا ودِّي أسألك عن أشياء
إن تبدَ لكم
تُسؤكم
لا، أحس مرَّة رهيب ودِّي أعرف الأشياء اللي دخلت
وأحس أنك أنت برضو مهتم بهوية الأشياء
فأنا ببدأ معك بأشياء كثيرة دخلت إلى الجزيرة العربية
غيَّرتنا ولّا ما غيَّرتنا؟
أشياء غيرتنا وارد، على حسب
شفت أنت كيف ما توقعت أني أسوِّي فيك...
لا تدخلني في مشاكل
فأشياء غيرتنا، فالحين عندنا اللغة، قبل شوي تكلمنا فيها
عندنا...
اليوم أفطرت فول وتميس
يا سلام
زين
بالعافية
وتذكرت مقالة للدكتور «عبدالسلام أبو علي»
كيف أن الفول والتَّميس أكلة سعودية
حسنًا
وقد لا يعجب البعض الكلام كذا في بدايته
أيش دَّعوة؟ سلامات؟أيش اللي الفول سعودي؟
بس هو كان يرمز للفكرة، بأن الفول فعلًا مصري
بلا شك
والتميس جاءك من بلاد ما وراء النهر
أيش اللي خلّاه سعودي؟
أنّ الخليط هذا هو السعودي
فلا يمكنك أن تأكل الفول والتَّميس مع بعض إلَّا في السعودية
فهي وجبة سعودية
ياسلام، أتفق تمامًا
في مستويين
في المستوى التأثيلي، يعني التَّأصيلي
يعني من فين جاءت؟
هذا شيء
وثقافيًّا هي أيش؟
من فين جاءت؟
لا يعني بالضرورة أن هي ما صارت جزء في هذه الثقافة
لأنه لو جئت بهذا المنطق تتعقب
ستجرد نفسك من كثير مما هو لك
ومنسوب لك، وأموره طيبة معاك
وكل الناس تظنه لك
ستجرد نفسك من هذا الامتياز
لأن هذا منطق فاسد
ثقافيَّة الشيء مش بالضرورة أنه يكون وُجد
وخُلق، وابتُكر بدايةً في هذه المنطقة الجغرافية
هي ثقافة، ولا يمكن لشيء أنه يدخل على ثقافة
إلَّا ويُطوَّر، ويُحوَّر فيه، ويُزاد فيه، ويُنقص منه
هذه يعني...
أنت تستطيع بقليل من التأمل تكتشف كثير من الأشياء حولك
هذا الصِّديرِي اللي تلبسه وألبسه
له أصل
إما أن يكون مطوَّر عن أصل عربي قديم
اللي هي العباءة أو الثوب القديم، ثم قُصَّت ثم...
طيب هذه عملية القص اللي حصلت
أو أنها تكون البدلة أو الجاكت نفسه
الصِّديري نفسه
أي الصِّديري نفسه وقُص
لأنه في اللبس الأجنبي فيه يُلبس تحت البدلة
الآن أقدر أسميها تأصيليًّا، وتأثيليًّا لازم أعيده إلى نقطة قبل
ثقافيًّا، ما أحد يلبسه على الثوب
هل هي سديري نسبة لسدير؟
ولّا صديري فهي الصَّدرية؟
الله أعلم
صدق أنا دائمًا...
فكرت فيها كثير
هل هي أصلًا صدريّة؟
صدريّة، الأصل صدريّة
صدريّة، يعني ما هي سديري
لا، السديري، صوت، يعني تحريف صوتي
قلت ممكن السديريين كانوا يلبسوها كثير فنسبوها
ما يستاهلوا...
صدق أنا بعرف
إذا هم مبسوطين بهذه الحقيقة، نجعلها حقيقة لا بأس
فعلًا يعني...
فمثل هذه...
الآن بهذا الاعتبار ثقافيًّا، هي تَرُوج
احنا ليش مستعجلين نجعل كل شيء ينتمي أو لا ينتمي لنا؟
يا أخي الحدِّية هذه
تجعلني أخسر كثير من المنطقة الرمادية
اللي أستطيع من خلالها تطوير الأشياء
وأنها تأخذ نموها داخل ثقافتي
وتجد تموضعها الصحيح داخل ثقافتي
مسألة سعودة الأشياء
ومسألة نفي السعودة عن الأشياء، إشكال؟
ليش؟ وأنا ودِّي آخُذ الأشياء حقتي، وأمتلكها حقيقةً
وما لا يمثلني، يعني ما لا يمثل هويتي الحقيقية
يجب عليك تعريف الهوية
أنه ليس لي
فإذا أحد جاء، وقال والله أن الجينز سعودي
فمنطقي أنِّي أنفي هذا
يجب أنِّي أنفيه، أن الجينز ليس سعوديًّا
وكونه ليس سعوديًّا لا يعني بالضرورة أنه ما تقدر تلبسه، البسه
وأنا بلبسه، وبقول لك أنه ما هو سعودي، وبلبسه
لكن أنت قاعد تفترض أنه جاء أحد، وزعم أن الجينز سعودي
صحيح
شوف في إشكاليتنا هذه
يعني هذه الإشكالية الوحيدة
الآن شائع لبس الجينز شائع جدًّا، وعملي جدًّا
لكن لو ما كنت تعلم أن أمريكا عاملة بربوقندا على مسألة الجينز
وأنه أمريكية الهوية تتم عبر أركان معينة
منها الجينز، والبرقر منها الـ...
لَمَا سَهُل عليك أن تنفي نسبته...
إلي
إليك
ليش؟ لأنه في المقابل عندك قطب يتبنى
وهو جزء من هويته فما راح...
فاهم؟
ماذا عن الأشياء اللي هي متوسطة؟
قد تكون، وقد لا تكون
ليش أنا أروح أعاملها بنفس الصدام هذا، والحدِّية
وكأنه نفيها سيثبت شيء، وإدخالها سينفي شيء
المسألة تيَّار ثقافي طبيعي قاعد
تمشي عليه عصور يتطور، وينمو بشكل طبيعي
تنمو في الثقافة أشياء تزهر ثم تشيخ وتموت
تنبت بدلها أشياء أخرى تشيخ وتموت
في أشياء تُفرض؟
نعم، الطَّرابيش عند الأتراك فُرضت فرضًا
وجاء اليوم ما فيه أتراك يلبسوا طَّرابيش
فُرضت عليهم العمائم ثم فُرضت الطَّرابيش
نعم السُّلطة لها أن تَفرض أشياء، ولها أن تُزيل أشياء
يعني عامل السُّلطة ولّا عامل القوة
يشيل في الثقافات ويضع، إي نعم بلاشك
واللغة كذلك لأنه لها جانب ثقافي كبير
والاجتماعي، والتَّاريخي. هي ما يمديك تفصلها فصل
وتقول لا، هذا أعامله معاملة ثقافية صرفة
ماشي، صح بس راح تظل نظرية
كبيرها بحث مُحكَّم، صلَّى الله وبارك
لكنك تعالج بها الإشكال؟ لا
تخليها مشروع قابل للتنفيذ؟ لا، لا يمكن
لازم تُدرس جميع النَّواحي
الثقافي ديني، والديني لغوي، واللغوي ثقافي، والتاريخي اجتماعي
والاجتماعي تاريخي
فيه نوع من التعاجن بين هذه العقول
وفصلها بموس، وتحديد ما هو دخيل وما هو...
لازم يتم عبر إطار مرجعي
إطار، وأحدد حُقبة ثمَّ أدرس على ضوء هذه الحقبة ما وفد
وكونه وافد أو دخيل أو أصيل أو...
المفترض أنه ما يحمل دلالة سلبية في البداية
الآن صار عندنا نوع من الـ...
دخيل وافد
لأنه ارتبط عندنا بفترة معينة في...
في وقت ما فقدنا تميزنا الحضاري
صار كل وافد ودخيل بالضرورة فيه شيء يُجبرك على التنازل الهويَّاتي
فارتبطت عندنا مسألة الدَّخيل، مع أنه ما كانت حساسة
نعم، العرب ما كانوا يحبوا اللي عيونهم زرق
كان يجد في نفسه من الفرس والروم
يجد في نفسه أنفة معينة
مع ذلك استفاد منهم، واستفاد من تأريخهم
واستفاد من تنظيمهم السياسي في الدواوين والبريد وغيره
ما في إشكالية
ولما نجي نروي نقول العرب
ترى احنا نتجوَّز تجوّزًا، ما هو كل العرب
فيه اللي كان بينهم إشكال أو اللي كانوا مُتَّاخمين لهم
واحد ثاني يمكن ما عنده مشكلة
لكن احنا نقولها، ودائمًا نترك للنبيه مسألة وضع القيود الداخلية
لأنه لو جئت أنت تقيد، وتستدرك على نفسك كل شيء ما انتهى الكلام
غلَّق العالم ما انتهى الكلام
فمثلًا يجيك واحد يقول لك العرب لبست كذا، صح؟
فالحكم أغلبي ممكن يكون أو حكم أكثري
وربما ما يكون حتى حكم أكثري، لكن نتجاوز
عبارتك ما هي محكمة
فتنفي مساحة للآخر أنه العرب لبست هكذا، ما لبست هكذا
خليني أعطيك...
مثلًا
فكرة أخرى أو رأي
فالآن احنا نقدر نقول أن الرز هندي أو أمريكي
ويندر، فيه عندنا الرز الحساوي، ولكنه على كميات قليلة ولا يُذكر
احنا في السعودية نستخدم الرز الهندي أو الأمريكي
لكن نقول أن الكبسة سعودية
ولِمَ نقول أن الكبسة سعودية؟
لأنها تطورت في هذا الشكل فقط في السعودية
نعم
فالعرب ما عندهم قطن
ولكنهم استخدموا القطن فيما هم يريدون أن يلبسوا
فاستخدام المواد الأولية في صناعة شيء أنت ترغبه
يجعله لك، خالص
وفي أي شيء. مثلًا العِمَامة
استخدمت بعض الأشياء أو استخدمت بعض الزخارف اللي تخليني...
اللي جبتها من أفغانستان ولّا من أي بلاد ثانية
هذا يجعلني أنا شفت شيء أعجبني، وأنا أعدت تطويره
وربمَّا هم طاوعوا رغبتك، وصاروا يصنعوه بهذه الطريقة
الشماغ اليوم معظمه يُصنَّع...
تلقاه إنقليزي أصلي، ومدري شلون
وهذا لا يعني أنه إنقليزي
فهو سعودي بغض النظر وين صنع
ماشي
حسنًا
فاللي أنا جالس أروح له
أن الأشياء تصبح أصيلة، وإن كانت بعضًا منها وافدة
متى ما استخدمت لشيء احنا نستخدمه
ما جاءمثلما هو وأنت استخدمته
طيب لو استخدمها معك قومٌ آخرون؟
أنا أتفق معك
إذا أنا طورته واستخدموه، هم استخدموا شيء من عندي
يمكن طوروه بطريقتهم اللي تناسبهم
بس طالما أنك أخذتها كذامثلما يقولون كما هو
فهو إذًا دخيل، ومفترض أنه ما يمثل ثقافتك
يعني لو جاء طربوش
فالطربوش لا يمكن تحت أي شكل من الأشكال
أن يمثِّل الثقافة السعودية تمامًا
إلا لو يوم كان الطربوش عندهم جبناه، وحطيته، وصار يلف على راسي
ما أدري
جاءت الحكومة، وقالت الطربوش يُعمم
في السعودية؟
مثلًا
يُعمم الطربوش، صار ثقافتك
أنت كمؤرخ ثقافي راح تقول أنه دخل دخولًا في هذا...
راح يجي واحد يقول لك
كم أحتاج من السنين حتى أقول إنه هو صار في الثقافة السعودية؟
تجد أن المسألة متداخلة
ويجيك واحد يستدرك عليك
مثلًا الشِّماغ ما أعرف إنه من إنقلترا مثلًا
هل هم أول من...
الإنقليز جعلوه تجاريًّا
لكن وُجد قبلهم ترى
في صورة قديمة 1919 ميلادي
فيه رجل سعوي يرتدي الشماغ الأحمر هذا المُرقَّط
اللي حصل أنه «قلوب باشا» قائد الجيش العربي في 1900
بعد الحرب العالمية
بعد الكساد اللي حصل في مصانع بريطانية
هذا اللي يُروى في بعض المذكرات
طلب أنه يصبح الزي الرسمي للجيش الأردني الشماغ الأحمر
فدخل عليهم بالشماغ الأحمر
ليش ما نقول احنا قاعدين نلبس الشماغ الأردني، مثلًا؟
صار لبسًا شائعًا عندنا، ودخل ووجد طريقه، واستراح
فيجيك واحد يقول لك لا، هو إنقليزي
هو قبلما يكون إنقليزي، ربما دخل بطريقة هدايا أو بشكل فردي
بعضهم يتعسف في إرجاع أصل الشماغ
إلى دولة الأمير الأكادي «قوديا»
لأنه وُجد في طراز معيّن، في منحوتة تمثال
لأحد أمراء العصر الأكادي
الأمير «قوديا» قبل...
2200 سنة قبل الميلاد. أن في رأسه لابس شماغ
وهي من أش وماخ، السومرية اللي تعني غطاء الرأس
لكن الصورة تظهره يلف غطاء الرأس
ما هو مسدله مثلًا
لكن بعد بحث طويل يوصلك لنتيجة أن الشماغ أساسًا سعودي
طيب سومري أو أكادي؟
لا، أصل السومرية والأكاديَّة والبابليَّة والأشوريَّة والعبرانيَّة
كلها تعود إلى اللغة العربية اليوم
أنا قد أتفق معك، صح ما في إشكال
لكن شوف كيف تعاملك مع قضية عشان تجعلها رمز
خلاك تروح لمناطق تعصب...
أنت أحلتني على التمثال
التمثال ما في له...
ثم اللي أنت قاعد تتكلم عليه كله ظنِّي
بغلبة الظَّن يثبت عادي ما في إشكال
وبوجود بعض القرائن يثبت عادي
بس شوف طريقة التعامل مع إثبات الشماغ
أنا أقول لك الشماغ ما في شك أنه سعودي تمامًا، ما هي قضية
بس هل تقدر تتفق معي بأن الأشياء اللي تكتسب...
خصوصية..
تعطي صبغة جديدة، وتطوير معين
تُنسب لأهل الـ...
بلا شك
وما دون ذلك صعب أنه يُنسب
هذا معيار، أنت حطِّيت لي ضابط واحد
في بعضهم يقول لك يا أخي في أشياء
قد تُسمى سعودية، ولا ينضبط عليها الضابط مثلًا
في بعض الأشياء، تطيُّبنا مثلًا بالعود
يا أخي تقليد سعودي
وشاركت فيه كثير من الأمم
لكن مع ذلك...
بنفس الطريقة كلهم على الجمر، ما فيه أحد على الفرن
كلهم على الجمر
تجد أنه ماشي
فتروح تحط لي ضابط ثاني، وضابط ثالث
وما في إشكال في هذا
لكن مسألة الثقافي المتعاجن هذا مع الاجتماعي
والتَّاريخي والدِّيني مسألة وضع الضوابط عليه
يحتاج لها نوع من الحذر لأنه مرَّة متُعاجنة المسألة
طيب، أيش الوجبة العربية الخالصة؟
اللي من جزيرة العرب
هو ممكن فلسفيًّا تقول اللي كان يُزرع ويُنتج عندهم، العَصِيدة
يالله افرح
ترى العَصِيدة من الوجبات اللي عرفها الانسان العربي القديم، وإلى اليوم مستمر
وإلى اليوم مستمر
الثريد
طيب اليوم وين العصيدة؟
شوف لها أكثر من صيغة
الثريد وين؟
أتوقع أن فيه ثريد
في ثريد نعم، اللي هو اللحم يبل مع المرق...
الخبز يبل بالمرق، ويحط عليه...
زي القرصان
هذا قبل لا يدخل الرز كانت هي الوجبة المعروفة
القُرصَان برضو أتوقع أنه من هالقبيل صح؟
إي، هي من التطور الطبيعي لها، نعم
والعصيدة والعريكة، ولّا العَرِيكة جديدة؟
العَرِيكة لا، الصيغة هذه موجودة في المعجم
لكن بعضهم عنده العريكة الخبز والسمن فقط
بعضهم الخبز والسمن والتمر
وبعضهم يجعلها مالحة، يعني في كل ثقافة...
والعصيدة مالحة، والعريكة حالية
الأصل أن العصيدة مالحة
وبعضهم يجعل العصيدة حلوة
في بعض الثقافات هنا في الجزيرة العربية
لكن أتكلم عن الإسم، نعم. قد تختلف الوصفة من منطقة لمنطقة
وقد أيش تعود إلى أي...؟
موجودة في المعجم، وموجودة في الشارع الجاهلي
وموجودة في أخبار العرب
احنا أصلًا ما نعرف عن أخبار العرب
إلَّا ما قبل البعثة النبوية ب250 سنة أقصى شيء
والمعصوب طيب؟
المعصوبة أو العصيبة موجودة كصيغة عربية
هي أيش العَصب؟
أيش العَصب؟
العملية هذه اسمها العَصب
أنك تَعصُب الشيء وتلويه وتقطعه وتعجنه هذه كلها عصبة
ومنها جاءت العصابة
لكن وصفتها الأساسية، ربَّما تختلف من مكان إلى مكان
مثلًا تقرأ في كتاب «عيون الأخبار» «لابن قتيبة»
باب الطعام أو كتاب الطعام
ادخل في لسان العرب، اكتب: العصبة أو المعصوبة أو المعصوب
أو العصيب أو العصيبة
تجد كل منطقة تستأثر بوصفة معينة
الحين برجع لأهم نقطة
ليه ما تكلمنا عن القهوة إلى...؟
الحين، هذه أهم نقطة
لاحظ أني قلت أهم نقطة
أوه، هذه حرب
أهم نقطة اللي هي القهوة
أهم نقطة بالنسبة لك طبعًا
بالنسبة لي المعصوب
لا، بالنسبة لكل الناس
أنت قاعد تشرب قهوة كل يوم، ما تأكل معصوب كل يوم
ما تبغي تعطيني الفضل هذا
فأنت عندك كتاب «ديوان القهوة» أنتجته مؤخرًا
شعر قهوة البُن من القرن التاسع الهجري
جمع، وتعليق ماجد بن عدنان الأهدل
أنعم، وأكرم
ومعه مقدمة جديدة في تاريخ القهوة
تأليف ماجد بن عدنان الأهدل
بس هذه الطريقة...
تراثية
تراثية ليش استخدمت الفكرة؟
موضوع تراثي لأني بدلل لك
على أنه معالجة موضوع القهوة تراثية في الأساس
لأنه أيش اليوم الجو؟
صرعة وموضة و«كول» وقهوة ومقاهي
بينما هو الموضوع في صميم تُراثك
فإذا تقول أن هذا الموضوع كذا
لا، أنا أعامله معاملة اللي هو...
لا، على طريقة المؤرخين العرب أو الأدباء العرب بنفس الطريقة
القهوة ليست دخيلة على العرب؟
أستغفر الله العظيم «اتفل من بؤك»
أنت تُفرق بين مستويين
مستوى الشجرة أو النبات «الثمرة» ومستوى المشروب
هذا مستوى، وهذا مستوى
النبتة، الشجرة، الثمرة
اختُلف في أصل نشأتها أنها في الحبشة
وقالوا جنوب السودان في هضبة بوما
معلش ودِّي نعرِّف الحبشة تاريخيَّا
يا سلام عليك
الحبشة السياسية غير الحبشة الثقافيَّة الجغرافية
الحبشة اللي يُنسب لها هذا البُن، ما هي الحبشة السياسية اليوم
كانت أعم من هذا، ثم إن كان هذا الكلام...
وحجيك للتفنيد
الحبشة، جنوب السودان هضبة «بوما» وجبل «مارسبت» في كينيا
واليمن
هذه أبحاث جينية قالت هذا
وبحث جيني آخر قال هذا، وبحث جيني ثالث قال هذا
واليمن لما جاؤوا عام 1964 بعثة فرنسية للحبشة
تبغى تدرس الأشجار جينيًّا
فيذهبوا إلى أكبر الأشجار ما وجدوها
ضربتها عاصفة، وأنهتها
فقالوا يا جماعة ما في دليل قاطع
وهذا علميًّا يفهمه العلماء، أن ما فيه دليل قاطع
غلبة الظن تقول، نعم
أنه؟
أنه من الحبشة، غلبة الظن
لكن تقطع وتجزم وتقيم معارك مع الناس على هذا الأساس؟ لا
لكن المشروب، لا يمكن النزاع حول عربيته
لا يمكن النزاع حول عربيته، بالدلائل المحسوسة والتاريخيَّة
لا يمكن...
هذا مستوى، وهذا مستوى
ممتاز. إذا كانت النبتة موجودة في الحبشة
نعم
فاحنا أتفقنا على هذا
أتفق نعم لا بأس
قد يكون أصلها في الحبشة
فأيش كانوا يسوون فيها؟
يمضغونها، تُمضغ
القهوة، والقات خرجوا في نفس التوقيت
القات كان يُشرب، والقهوة كانت تُمضغ
عادة العربي لا يُسيغ فكرة المضغ
فكرة الإجترار هذه، لا يستيغها، تأباها نفسه
راح يجينا هذا الكلام على مسألة من اكتشف القهوة؟
لما تجي تدرس روايات نشأة القهوة في التراث العربي عندك
تجدها تنقسم إلى اتجاهين
اتجاه ميثولوجي أسطوري، واتجاه معقول
هناك من يقول أنها من الجنة في الأصل
أنه الجنة هي الموطن الأصلي للـ...
ليش؟
«علوان الحموي» توفى عام 1936
له رسالة اسمها «السر المكنون في مدح البُون» أو في فضائل البُون
يروي عن «أبي القاسم، المشرّع، الجُنيد» توفي عام 1917
هجري؟
أنت تستخدم الهجري
تراثي نعم، إذا احتجت ميلادي قول لي
بأنها أُهبطت مع آدم عليه السلام لمَّا أهبطه الله للأرض تسليةً له
بعدين يقول...
في «الشيخ سليمان بن يوسف بن عمر البسيوني»
في «تحفة الإخوان» كان يقول...
« لما روى أئمة معتبرة بأن أصلها من الجنان، تُسمى لديهم شجرة السلوان
قد أُهبطت مع آدم لما نزل، وهكذا شيخ مشايخي نقل
غرسها سبعون ألف ملك»
كانت له أرجوزة اسمها «تحفة الإخوان» فينقل هذا
ورأيي طبعًا أُشع
له أصل؟
الأمور الغيبية كانت سيُنص عليها
آدم، عليه السلام، نزل نزولًا
نيجي لمسألة «الملك داود» في العبرانيَّة
داود عليه السلام
كثير من الباحثين الغربيين يقول أنه في «سفر راعوث» اليهودي
و «سفر التكوين» و«سفر صموئيل الثاني» أنها ذُكرت
يقول لك قدموا لها خبزًا وفريكًا ودقيقًا وشعيرًا
قال الفريك هذا هو الخضار المشوية هي البُن
ما في دليل على هذا، أنت قلتها خلاص ومصدق؟
آخر يقول لك لا، هي وُجدت في «سفر صموئيل الثاني»
وفي إصحاح من «سفر راعوث»
طبعًا كلها كلام...
اللي أشاعه أول مرَّة «جورج باش» فيلسوف بولندي
هو أول من أشاع هذا الفكرة، وقال ليش ما تكون هي النبيذ الأحمر؟
هو اللي في «سفر صموئيل الثاني» اللي هو القهوة
ما أحد سبقك إلى هذا
يجيك بعده يقول لك في «إلياذة هوميروس»
ذُكرت فيها أنه «هيلين» ابنة «زيوس»
لما جاءت، وشافت أبوها تعبان
كانت قد أحضرت له من مصر حبوبًا معينة
سحقتها مع النبيذ سموه الـ «نابط»
«النابط» هذا مشروب مفرح، قال هذه القهوة
مصر يا مولانا لا تُزرع فيها قهوة. ويعني فوضى
تجي تنزل تحتها يقول لك نبي الله سليمان بن داود
هذا الرأي ذكره « ابن العماد الحنبلي» في «شذرات الذهب»
يرويه عن«محمد الغزِّي» أخو «نجم الدين الغزِّي»
صاحب«الكواكب السائرة»
يقول أنه نبي الله سليمان
في إحدى رحلاته، ونزل على قوم، نفس القضية
تجد أن تاريخها الأول مرتبط دائمًا بأشخاص خارقين للعادة
أنبياء وملائكة، بعدين جاؤوا لنبي الله محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وأنَّ جبريل نزل عليه، وجاؤوه قوم من أهل اليمن في الحج
وقالوا له يا رسول الله بنا علَّة وكذا، فوصفها لهم
هذا كلام عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فين يعني؟
ليش غاب عنَّا؟
من زيادات وشطحات بعض الصُّوفيَّة
انزل يجي يقول لك بعدها الرَّاعي، في سالفة الرَّاعي
تخيل أنه مسألة «خالدي» هذا اللي يُزعم...
ما أحد قال أنه أثيوبي
حتى الفرنسيين والإيطاليين ما أحد قال إنه أثيوبي
كانوا يقولوا إنه راعي يمني
يحصل تشويه في رواية واحدة
وخلاص تُعتمد رواية صغيرة لأنها تنسب الحق
«خالدي» هذا في إثنا عشر رواية عربية
تقول أنه كان يرعى الإبل، ومرّة نعاج، ومرَّة شياه، ومرَّة...
في عدن
لما أكلت النعاج من هذه الشجرة فوجدت في نفسها انشراحًا وانبساطًا
وقامت ترقص فجربها...
إلى آخر القصة المشهورة
طبعًا هذا كلام واضح أنه هو فيه فجوة تاريخيَّة حصلت
فإنسان يبغى يسد هذه الفجوة، فألف هذه القصة
تجي بعدها للتيار المحسوس
ربَّما يكون أصل القصة هكذا
ثم بعد ذلك جاء من عرف خواصها، وإكتشفها ربَّما
تجي لناس محسوسة معروفة لها تراثها
ولها ذراري معروفة...
تقاسم هذا الشرف ثلاثة
«علي بن عمر الشاذلي» أقدمهم
و«محمد بن سعيد الذبحاني»
و«أبو بكر بن عبدالله العيدروس»
«أبو بكر بن عبدالله العيدروس» ولد عام 850 وتوفي عام 914
اللي نسب له الغزِّي في «الكواكب السائرة»
نقلًا عن «ابن طول»
إذًا انفراد مؤرخ شامي ما جاء لليمن، ولا عرف...
وأرَّخ له هذا «أبو بكر بن عبدالله العيدروس»
تلامذته «علي الحلبي» وابنه
في ترجمة موسعة ذكروا فيها أخباره مع القهوة
لكن ما ذكروا أنه اكتشفها
ترجم له ابن أخيه في «النور السافر»
«عبدالقادر بن شيخ العيدروس» ما ذكر هذه القصة
في المدونات اليمنية لا توجد قصة اكتشافه
لكن لسطوته الثقافيَّة على المنطقة
وكان رجل له أتباع ومُريدين كُثر
وكان يقيم مآدب وكان يسقي الناس القهوة
فليش ما...؟
هي تبدأ هكذا ثم يصير لها انحراف، ويجيك مؤرخ، انتهى
«محمد بن سعيد الذبحاني»
اللي هو «جمال الدين»
«جمال الدين» نعم
هذا اللي قاعد يروج مؤخرًا أنه هو مكتشف القهوة
«جمال الدين الذبحاني محمد بن سعيد» توفي عام 875
ما نقل هذا القول إلَّا «ابن عبدالغفار» في «دفع الهفوة»
لأنه أصلًا القول هذا هو استفتى فيه رجلًا من أهل اليمن في زبيد
قال له استخبر لي من تعرف من كبار السن
عن أول أمر هذه القهوة، ومن أول من شربها
فقال له رجل يقال له «محمد بن سعيد الذبحاني»
فشك، في «دفع الهفوة» هذا لـ «ابن عبدالغفار»
جاء «الجزيري» في «عمدة الصفوة» واختصر
«دفع الهفوة» جاء من بعده...
طبعًا تُعقِّب «ابن عبدالغفار»
الدكتور «عبدالودود مقشر» وأتفق معه في هذا الرأي، وتوجيهه
أنه ليس «محمد بن سعيد الذبحاني» وَهِم
إنما هو «محمد بن سعيد الطبري»
ثمَّ، سنة انتقال والد «محمد بن سعيد الذبحاني»
إلى عدن كانت عام 842
«محمد بن سعيد» من قبلها كان عنده تأليف في القهوة
كيف اكتشفها، وهي معروفة من قبله؟
وله فيها تأليف، وكان يجيد الحبشية
اللغة الحبشية
فإن كان من رجل يُعزى له هذا الاكتشاف، فليكن هذا
«محمد بن سعيد» فيسقط القول الثاني
«علي بن عمر الشاذلي» هو محل الإجماع
ولد 750، توفي عام 828 هجري
له رحلة إلى الحبشة، وتزوج ابنة أخ السلطان «سعد الدين المجاهد»
اللي كان  في مملكة عَفَت وقتها، وكانت مملكة إسلامية عربية
أصلهم إلى «عقيل بن أبي طالب» جَبَرت
فمملكة عربية إسلامية
وكانت تتصارع مع الممالك الوثنية في الحبشة
على فرض أنه اكتشفها هناك، فهي حبشة عربية إسلامية
مع أنِّي أقول يا عمي ما في مشكلة خليها تكون...
هذه النبتة ما عندي جدال في هذا
أنا الآن ما أبغى أقول النبتة عندي وأجادل في قضية ربَّما
يجيك واحد يقول لك، طيب قبل الحبشة كانت تزرع
المشروب، احنا نبغى نمسك الشغلة اللي اعترف لنا العالم فيها
من المؤسف أن نقول الكلام ذا
هو قال لك، أنه هذه هدية العرب للعالم
يا أخي أمسك فيها، عُض عليها بالنَّواجد واستثمرها
وأنا أشوف إلى اليوم ما استُثمرت استثمار صحيح
أبدًا، لأنه فيه ناس أصلًا ما هي مقتنعة بالقضية هذه
بعربيَّة القهوة؟
أي، في ناس طارئين على البحث
فيه ناس عنده اشكال، عنده هو اشكال شخصي نفسي مع نفسه
إذا جلس مع نفسه ممكن يبكي ويكتئب
لأن هو ممكن تتصارع مع مع ذباب وجهه
عنده إشكال، وعنده أزمة نفسية، هذا ما أرجو منه أنه يؤرخ
عرفها العرب قولًا واحدًا، لا مثنويَّةَ فيه
أهدوها للعالم عرفوا هذه الحبوب، واستزرعوها
أزيدك من الشعر بيت؟
حتى البُن الذي وجد في الحبشة ذلك الزمان كان بريًّا وحشيًّا
الذي أدخل زراعة البُن إلى الحبشة يمني
يعني استزرعوها ونظَّموها ثم جابوها مرة أخرى إلى الحبشة
الحبشة متى صدَّرت البُن؟ بعد الـ 1850
صدَّرت البُن متأخرة
«الجبرتي» في «عجائب الآثار»
يروي أنه في فترة من الفترات انقطع البُن
اليمن تصدر 100% من البُن
انقطع عن مصر البُن اليمني، فاضطروا إلى البُن النوبي
ما في بالنوبة البُن، هو يقصد الحبشي
قال لكنه كان أردأ
ولا يَسِيغه الجُند والعسكر
وما صدَّقوا رجعت الإرساليات من المخا إلى جدة إلى السويس
استزرعوه، حضنته ثقافة صوفيَّة
الناس لمَّا ييجوا يأرِّخوا، ويحاولوا أنه هذه القضية يختصرها
أنت عندك...
يا أخي احنا نتكلم عن مبحث علمي تاريخي وفِّه حقَّه
احتضنته الصوفية
بل أن الذي أشاعها وجعل لها هذا الرَّونق العالمي، وهذا السحر
هم الصُّوفية، راح أجي على...
طبعًا دخلت في البداية في سياق العبادي
الإعانة على السهر، حتى أن مكتشف القهوة «علي بن عمر الشاذلي»
يقول: قهوة البُن يا أهل الغرام، ساعدتني على طرد المنام
وأعانتني بعون الله على طاعة المولى، والنَّاس نيام
قافها القوَّة، وَالْهَاءُ هُدى، وواوها الْوُدْ، وَالْهَاءُ هِيَامٌ
إلى آخره
إذًا ذُكرت في شعره
وهذا لعلَّه أول ناقل في الشعر
أوصى بها «مريدي» تهجّد، وما كانت تُشرب كما نشرب القهوة اليوم
كما نسكب ونشرب، هي ما كانت تُشرب
كانت عبارة عن طقس
لازم تُقرأ قبله شيء من الأوراق
لازم تُشرب في أماكن طاهرة
لازم...
كان لها ترتيب
تقرأ ياسين، ومئة لا إله إلا الله، ومئة سبحان الله
ومئة الله أكبر، ومئة الحمد لله، إلى آخره
عشان تشرب بس فنجان
يبرد يمكن مئة مرة
طبعًا بلا شك هم يصبوها بعد الرَّاتبة هذه
يسموها الرَّاتبة أو الوِرد
بعضهم قال: وِردَها مئة وستَّة عشر يا قوي
ليش؟
قال: لأنه في حساب الجُمَّل
طريقة حساب أنه يعطي كل حرف قيمة
يا قوي أو قوي تساوي في حساب الجُمَّل، قهوة
بتسكين التَاء، فقالوا وردها القهوة
وردها يا قوي 116
لأن الحساب 116، فقول يا قوي 116
وبرعوا في مثل هذا
ووُجدت كثير من الفواتح حولها، والتَّراتيب
وعدد الفناجين، تراتيب خاصة
خرجت للناس بفعل الموالد، وبفعل الاحتفالات العامة
عرفها العامة
بدأت تصير أصلًا غلَّة زراعية
مجرد صارت غلَّة، ومحصوليَّة تَدِر
بدؤوا الناس، أنت محتاج غلَّة محصولية؟
يعني لازم فيه طلب فالناس طلبتها، ودفعت عليها فلوس
الناس بدأت تستزرع، وبدأت تُصدِّر
وصلت إلى مكة، حدثت وقتها
في مكة عام 917 الهجرية الخلاف الشَّهير
طبعًا هنا إشكال
لو تجي تشوف كيف يتعامل الرُّواه الغربيون مع هذه القضية
أن الإسلام حرَّم القهوة
لا، الإسلام ما حرَّم القهوة
هذا كلام عنوان فقط، لكنه كلام فارغ
بس الكل يقول كذا سواءً...
هذه الإشكالية، صح
إشكاليَّة اللي يقف عند الباب
حصل تحريم سياسي لها، وحصل خلاف فقهي ما يُنكر
كم دام؟ شهر
بس؟
ما عادت تُشرب، وأبشرك نفس اليوم كانت تشرب
أيش تقصد بالتحريم السياسي؟
وتفريقه عن التحريم...
يا أخي كان في هذا «خاير بك»
متولي الحسبة في مكة أو والي الحرم أو أمير مكة هكذا يُسمى
وكان هناك أخوين طبيبين وحكيمين أعجميين
اسمهم «علاء الدين» و«أحمد الكازاروني»
مولانا هذا «خاير بك» كان راجع ليلة ثلاثة وعشرين ربيع...
راجع من الحرم بعد أن طاف ما شاء
وسنّن وباس الحجر وقبّله وبكى
وراجع بيته مسكين إلَّا يشوف ناس
عند المسعى يتمايلون، ويديرون بينهم كأس
فأوجس في نفسه يا أخي أنا مو متولِّي الحسبة؟
أنكرت هذا اللي يقومون به
فذهبوا يُديرون شرابًا على هيئة الخمر بينهم
المهم كبَّروا القضية، ومن الغد استدعى العلماء من جميع المذاهب
وقال لهم: يا جماعة الخير أفتونا في مثل هذا الأمر
قالوا والله أمره للطب
فجاؤوا الأطباء قالوا بارد، ويابس فيه إشكال
فانتهينا قولًا واحدًا
يا جماعة الخير ادفع، افعل، اترك
قولًا واحدًا: بارد ويابس ومُضر
وجاؤوا إثنين شهود واحد اسمه «حافظ الأعمى»
وواحد اسمه فيه ما يُستنكر وما لا يُقال
فجاؤوا الشهود وألبسهم لبس المعممين وكذا
وجلَّسوهم عشان يبدو عليهم الوقار، قالوا لهم أيش رأيكم؟
قالوا جرَّبناها، وأسكرت
شهادة المُجرِّب، عدل المُجرِّب شهد؛ فحرَّمها
وقال للمشايخ: اكتبوا لنا هذا التحريم، ونرفعه للسلطان «قانصوه الغوري»
سؤال لمشايخ مصر وقتها والأزهر و...
فلمَّا رفعوه للسلطان «قانصوه الغوري» في عام 918
جاء بالجواب قال: أما إدارتها بهذه الهيئة فالإدارة...
لو كانت ماءً تَحرم؛ إذا كان يقصد التَّشبه
أمَّا ما فيه فأمره بذاته فلا نستطيع أن نجزم
كلام سياسي دبلوماسي. فأرسله للعلماء في مصر
العلماء منهم من حرّم، لأنه سمع سماعًا
الشهادة وهي توجب أن تحكم بها
وأنت أسير سؤالك
إذا جاءك واحد سألك
قال لك: والله يا أخي شربت شيئًا، وشعرت أنه رأسي يدور...
ووجدت أنِّي سكران، حرام، نقطة
أنت أسير هذا السؤال
ما تقضي بعلمك، وما تفتي بعلمك
فمعظمهم كان هذا السؤال اللي يوصلهم
يا شيخ، يلهي عن الصلاة و...
وترى يشرب في حضرة المردان والنساء والاختلاط، وكما تعلم يا شيخنا
تحفه بكل هذه المنكرات، ويجي يقول حلال؟ لا
فهذا اللي كان يحصل، وإذا تقرأ المرسوم تجده بهذه الصيغة
طيب، جاء هذا التحريم بعضهم قال حرام، احتفلوا بها الناس
وصار المُحرِّم يعتمد على ما أفتى به مشايخ الإسلام وقتها في مصر
خلاص قال مولانا شيخ الإسلام «زكريا الأنصاري» كذا
قال مولانا «يحيى الدميري» كذا، وقال مولانا...
طيب هو قوله على ما وصله من سؤال
وهذه فكرة «دفع الهفوة» لـ«ابن عبدالغفار»
قال يا حبيبي نقسم المسألة
السؤال اللي وصلهم هكذا فكيف تبغى يكون إجابته؟
وهو راح أرسل لهؤلاء العلماء، بعد هذه الحادثة
قال لهم: يا جماعة الخير هل رجعتوا عن فتاويكم؟ بعضهم رجع
بعضهم كان قد توفي وأفضى إلى ما قدَّم
وقامت حرب ضروس على المستوى الأدبي
أما على مستوى الاستعمال، فكانت تُشرب، أبشرك
بل أن «ابن حجر الهَيتَمي» المكِّي
روَى في ثَبَته أن كانت المراسيم أو الفرمانات
المراسيم السلطانية تأتي بمنع القهوة
لأن يجيك واحد يرفع قضية فيجي لازم نجامله
فيجي المرسوم السلطاني، بأن تُمنع القهوة من الأسواق
يلف الفرمان. ويدخل مقهى، ويشرب قهوة ويمشي
هذا اللي قاعد يروي المرسوم السلطاني
فكان يقول فما كانت تبلغ منهم إلا كتحلَّة القسم
أنه بس يبلغك
فيقول لك إذا أدرنا ظهورنا فافعلوا ما شئتم
هذا الضابط اللي المفترض أنه يتلو البيان و...
كان يقول «ابن حجر» إذا أدرنا ظهورنا فافعلوا ما شئتم، روَى في ثَبَته
إذًا مسألة تحريم الإسلام لكذا، ولوسمه لا
حصل تحريم، وله أن يكون هذا التَّحريم
إذا بلغت هذه الصورة
إذا صورته صارت كذا، لابد أنه يكون مُحرَّم
لكنه حُرِّمت، وقُمعَت
طيب «مراد الرابع» لمَّا كان يقتل على القهوة والتتن في إسطنبول
ما هو لحرمتها
الرجل كان يعني...
كانت الخمور تُباع في كل مكان، ما هو لحرمتها
الإنكشاريين كان شعارهم هذا اللي تمردوا عليه
كان أيش شعارهم؟ التَّدخين «التتن» والقهوة
فقال اللي تشوفه يدخن ويُتَتِّن لا تسأله
على طول
فجاؤوا قال آه شوف...
لا «بجوي إبراهيم» له كتابه، وقال أنه هذه القضية
وقال مرَّة مُنعت لأنه حدث حريق في بعض المقاهي
أدَّى إلى التهام أحياء كاملة في اسطنبول، وقتها حصل المنع
لمَّا ما تعرف هذه الدَّوافع
خلاص أنا بضرب سمعة معينة، بضرب الإسلام، وبضرب الأتراك
وبضرب كذا، سهل كل واحد يستطيع يعمل اللعبة هذه
حقيقةً ما حُرِّمت
فيه سؤال جميل...
آخذ راحتي؟
بس طيب أنا عندي...
قول لي
بس ودِّي تتذكر سؤالك اللي تبغى تسأله لنفسك، وتجيب عليه
بس أنا عندي سؤال: الحين وصولها إلى مكة
فهي يوم وصلت، بدأت سالفة التَّحريم؟
لا، هذه واحدة من الأشياء اللي أنا تعقبتها على كثير من المؤرخين
هم يقولوا أنها وصلت عام 900
وأنا أرى أنها وصلت عام 800
إلى مكة؟
نعم.
يعني قبل...
من اللي اعتمد على هذا الكلام؟
يقول «ابن عبدالغفار» أنها وصلت قبل الـ900 بسنوات
بس ما حدد
وجدت خبرًا، وليش أنا أقول لك أنها مقدمة جليلة؟
واحد يقول لي يا أخي مستحيل تكون مقدمة جليلة؟
قلت له ما هو أنا اللي سمِّيتها
أحدهم، اطلع على المسودة وقال لي: هذه مقدمة جليلة
ليش؟ لأنه فيها استدراك على كثير من البحوث التاريخيَّة
«محمد بن أحمد الرُّدَيني» حضر إلى مكة عام 827، وتوفي عام 826
حضر إلى مكة، ورُوِيَ أنه شرب القهوة في الحرم فمنعه قاضيه
هل قد يكون أنه في شراب آخر باسم القهوة غير القهوة؟
الخمر
فممكن يُذكر أنه شرب القهوة في الحرم يقصد بها غير القهوة؟
لا، يقيدوها بالبُن
واحد فقيه ولّا عالم يدخل الحرم يشرب ماهي...
ما بيسيبوه لا، يقصد القهوة
أنه قال: فأمر الساقي أن يزيد في الماجوري مرتين
أنه يطبخ طبخ، ويتم الطبخ. قهوة البُن
أصلًا «قهوة» اسم من أسماء الخمر
لأنها تُقهِي شاربها؛ أي تُشبعه وتقلِّل شهوته في الطعام
فجاء في شعر «الأعشى»
نازعتهم قُضب الريحان متكئًا
وقهوةً مُزَّةٌ راوُوقُها خَضِلُ
«حسَّان بن ثابت»
كأن فاها قهوةٌ مزةٌ، حديثة العهد بفضِّ الختام
يقصد بها أيش؟
يقصد بها الخمرة
الخمر، وليش اختِير لها الـ...
ما يُعرف، لكن لأنّ أصلًا الصوفية كان عندهم
نوع من التواجد على هذه الخمرة
فكانوا يذكرونها كثيرًا في أشعارهم الخمرة
الشَّمول والخمرة والسلاف، تعرف تشيع
لكن لما يبدو لي، وجدوا من خاصيتها أنها تُقهي عن الطعام فعلًا
فاختاروه لها
يوم وصل مكة متى حُرِّم؟
أول مشاكل الـ...
نعم، هجري
وأعتقد أنها القهوة نضجت في الجزيرة العربية، ومن ثم خرجت
بلا شك
خارج الجزيرة
متى خرجت من الجزيرة العربية؟
وصلت لـ...
خليني أقول 900 وصلت إلى مصر
وإلى الشام 941 هجرية
إسطنبول 962 هجري
وصلتها 962، هذا بحسب روايات الأتراك أنفسهم
962 خرجت من الجزيرة. خرجت مكتملة الشُّروط
وخرجت بمقهى مكتمل الشُّروط
أيش تقصد؟
القهوة، اليوم يظن الناس أنَّ الغرب
هو من أضاف إليها ما نعرفه اليوم من مضافاتها
الثلج والحليب والسكر والهيل
وهذا كلام عارٍ عن الصحة تمامًا
العرب حتى قبلما تخرج من اليمن ربما
عرفوا هذه المضافات جميعها
كلها؟ حتى الحليب؟
نعم
والسُّكر؟
«ابن عبدالغفار»
نعم
هذه عُرفت
دائمًا حتَّى تندُّرًا نسميها مُزَجَّديَّة
نسبةً إلى «أحمد بن عمر المُزَجَّد» صاحب «العُبَاب»
فقيه شافعي كبير
روى عنه خبر «ابن عبدالغفار» يقول:
وفي مرض موته منعه الطبيب من القهوة
لأنه كان مكثر منها فَتَقرَّحت معدته
فما يصلها طعام
فاحتالوا عليه بمزجها بالحليب
930 توفي. مرض قبلها بكم سنة كان يشرب
إذًا 927 أو 926 هكذا
فالَّاتيه كان يُستخدم في الجزيرة العربية؟
كانت تستخدم نعم بالحليب
عام 930؟
قبل
قبل 930
«أحمد بن علوي باجحدب» تُوفى 963
وقصيدة «بامخرمة» 950
توفي 950 قبلها، كان يروي أنه أضف إليها القند
«أحمد بن علوي باجحدب» ما له ذرية
لكن كان النقيب الباعلوي في زمانه في وقتهم أو من نقبائهم
لمَّا نفس الفكرة
احتالوا عليه بإيصال نوع غذاءٍ إلى جوفه بالسكر
«عبدالرحمن بن أبي بكر السكران» كان يُحبها باردة
وكان يقول: القهوة الباردة تطرد الشياطين الماردة
900 و...
في هذه الحدود 930-929
كان يقول هذه مأثورة عنَّه
هذا «الكولد برو»
«الكولد برو» التحضير بالطريقة الباردة
واحد يقول لك بالثَّلج لا، مو بالضرورة
التحضير بالطريقة الباردة
بثلج بغيره اللي هو
بل أنه في الشام كذلك عُرفت بالثلج
أنه كان...
فكانوا يحتفظون ببعض الثلج، ويضعونه في القهوة
يحبونها بهذه الطريقة
حتى الثلج كان يُصنع
الناس ما تصدق هذا كان يُصنع حتى في زمن قبل التبريد
الهيل والقرنفل والزنجبيل والمسك والعود والزَّباد
شفت قهوة لواك؟
هذه القهوة اللي من الحيوان هذا؟
عرفها العرب
بس ما كانوا يجعلونه يأكلها حتى يخرجها...
لا...
كانوا يستخرجونها من غُدَّته هذا
وكانوا يجيبون من الحبشة هذا الزَّباد
يصل إلى عدن، وكانوا يستخدمونه مع القهوة
إلى قريب «الشِّمطرِي» يسموه
إلى قريب وكانوا...
أعرف من كان يستخدمه من بعض قبائل الجنوب
كانوا يستخدموه برأس عود هكذا يضعه في الدَّلة
فإذا بها يعني تفوح، وتضوج
ويجيك اليوم «قهوة الزباد»
هي هي
اللهم أنت اخترت أن يمر بأحشائه، وأنا اخترت ألَّا أفعل
هذه كلها ذكرها ابن...
هذه كلها مكتوبة؟
هذه مثبتة
الحين اكتُشفت عام كم؟
اكتشفها وفقًا لرواية...
قبل 828 أو كانت تُشرب قبل 828 هجرية
وخرجت من الجزيرة العربية عام كم؟
فلك أن تتصور
يعني فترة طويلة جدًّا
طويلة جدًّا
ففي هذه الفترة ما ذُكر في العالم
ذِكر القهوة، وشرابها خارج الجزيرة العربية؟
مر بعض الرُّحال «راوولف» مثلًا مر عام 1983
بحلب وقال: أني وجدت هذا البُن يُشرب فيها وكذا
يعني وصل الخبر
لكن كانت وقتها قد وصلت إلى أسطنبول
فيه من رأى ومن سمع
لكن ما كانت بالانتشار العولمي اللي قاعدين نشوفه اليوم
إذا جاء في حواضر كبيرة
رُبَّما يراها يرى بعض مقاهيها يرى بعض الناس يشربوها
مش بالضرورة يعرف ما هي حتى يصفها
وإذا سأل، وكان من اللي كان عندهم هذه الحس الفضولي رُبَّما يعرف
«راوولف» منهم
فهي اكتشفت، وتطورت وتبلـ...
بدرجات الحَمص، نعم
العلَّامة «حمزة بن عبدالله النَّاشري» توفي عام 926
له قصيدة طويلة اسمها «جلب الزبون في مدح البُون»
البُون ترى هو كان اسمها الأساسي
اسم البُن
واحدة من المسائل اللي تخليني أرجِّح كون الثمرة عُرفت في الحبشة
هي أن اسمها البُون
احنا اختصرناها بُن
طيب البُن موجودة في الثقافة العربية؟
كلمة البُن موجودة، نعم
وهي أكلة كانت تصنع من مريء الحوت
ويضاف إليها بعض الخل، والأبازير
وكانت طعام طلبة العلم
حتى القاضي...
القاضي «أبو يوسف» صاحب الإمام «أبي حنيفة»
كان يقول: لا يعرف العلم من لم يحرق البُن قلبه
من كُثر ما يأكل البُن ما في وقت نسوي عصيدة و...
بُن سريع لأنه تأخذ الخبز، وتُسرِع على الدَّرس
كذلك في تقليب...
شراء العبيد وتقليب الـ...
مخطوط لـ«ابن بطلان البغدادي»
كان يقول لك الحيل اللي كانوا يسوُّوها النَّخاسين
عشان يبيعك الجارية، أنه كان يؤكلهم هذا الُبن
لأنه يطيب نكهة الفم فتحس أنه هي...
فتشتري
سمَّاه البُن، يطيب النكهة ورد بهذا الـ...
بس ما كان هو البُن اللي نعرفه، بُن القهوة
هذا اسم ثاني تطوَّر، صار بُن
أصله بون
البون بالواو
فجلست قرابة مئة و...
قول مئة وخمسين تقريبًا
مئة وخمسين سنة داخل الجزيرة العربيَّة
بتطورها وحمصاتها ووصفاتها وأشكالها
وحتى بطقوسها، خرجت جاهزة الطقس
اليوم نظن أنه...
ليش اليوم في مثلًا في الثَّقافة السعودية يشرب الفنجان الأول مُعد القهوة؟
إن كانت اختفت
كانوا يسموه فنجان الهيف مثلًا
هو لأنه تطمئن ضيفك أنَّ هذه القهوة ما بها سموم
أنه جودتها عالية تتأكد من ذلك، ليش؟
كان هذه ضرورة أول يوم كان القرن العاشر
قرن الاغتيالات السياسية بالسَّم
لا بد لك أن تطمئنه بشربك له
ذكرها «حمزه الناشري»
قال: إن كنت أيش...
إذا كان معك أحد، وكنت منه آكلًا فكل منه...
فكل أنت منه أولَّا، لألَّا يُسيء الظن أنك جاعلٌ له
فيه شيئًا من سموم ليُقتلا
كُل قبله
وعُرف ترى في مكة بداية الأمر مأكولًا
وعُرف في اليمن بداية الأمر مأكولًا، ومشروبًا
كذلك في مكة
فأنك تأخذ رأي كذا وتحزم به، وتصرح بـ...
أنا ودِّي أعرف كثير من الأشياء
في كيف أصلًا أنتقل من الحضر إلى البادية؟
وكيف أخذ هذه الطُّقوس؟
بس نأخذ فاصل، ونواصل
أعزائي المُشاهدين
عُدنا
يا هلا
«سبيستون» صح؟
«سبيستون» عُدنا
كانت أيَّام جميلة
الحين ودِّي أعرف تحوّل الـ...
كيف تغيرت داخل الجزيرة العربية؟
لعل هذا ما يهمني في الموضوع
بعدين باجي على سعودية القهوة
ولكن، ودِّي أعرف كيف داخل الجزيرة العربية تغيرت ما بين أنها...
في الطقوس الصوفية إلى أنها تصبح...
لا يوجد أعتقد أي شيء مأكول أو مشروب يحظى بهذه الحساسية
تجاه كيف يقدم، ولمَ يقدم، ولمن يقدم؟
تلقى مثلًا الآن عندهم نَجر، ويبدؤوا يدقونه
فإذا أعطاك الصوت فيبدأ الآن يعلمك أنه بيبدأ يقدم القهوة
وعلى ذلك فقِس
إذا هز الفنجان يعتبر أنه جالس يقول لك خلصت، وغيرها
طبعًا صُب لي ربع الفنجان زيادته فيها...
فيها معنى زائد
فيها إهانة، تفضَّل آسف
أقول من حسن حظ القهوة أنها نشأت في بيئة صوفيَّة
من حسن حظها؟
ليش؟ يا أخي طبيعة التَّصوف
طبعًا أنا قاعد أتكلم عن التَّصوف الشَّاذلي في هذاك الزمان
أنت تشوف التَّصوف الشَّاذلي لحدٍ ما كان، ما هو شاطح
لكن مع ذلك الصُّوفيَّة يعتنون بمسألة المعاني
ويتكلَّفون نوع من الرُّسوم، والتقاليد
يجبرون أنفسهم عليها كنوع من رياضة النفس
أول ما دخلت القهوة، ما دخلت كحاجة مُلِحَّة
تقوم عليها حياتك
إنَّما هي معنى زائد في أيش؟
أنه يجعلني أسهر الليل للتعبد والتَّأمل والتَّفكر
فهي ارتبطت من يومها الأول بطقس
وصار مشروبًا طقوسيًّا
كان مشروبًا طقوسيًّا ثم خرج إلى الاجتماع
في هذه الفترة رُتِّب عليه تراتب
الصُّوفيَّة عندهم انتظام، عندك شيخ، وأنت مُرِيد
تُريد ماذا؟ تُريد السُّلوك
ليش؟ للوصول
فعندهم هذه التراتيب
لهم معجمهم الخاص، ولهم التَّراتُبيَّة في الأدوار
القُطبيّة والغَوثيّة والوتديّة، أسماء
الوليّ والقطب والعارف والسَّالك والمُسلِّك
هذا الثَّراء المُعجمي عندهم
يوحي لك أنه هم ناس عندهم نوع من الصَّرامة في التراتبية، والطُّقوسية
لما تجي تنتقل إلَّا ما ينتقل معها شيء من رواسب الثقافة السابقة
لا يمكن أنها تجي تصير فيا لله نيجي ننظف، لا
لمَّا الاجتماعات الخاصة هذه صار فيها نوع من العموم
في المناسبات الدينية الكبرى
كالمواليد كـ...
كإطعام الطعام وكذا، تعرفوا الناس على القهوة
بدأت تُشرب، وبدأت تنزل إلى طبقة أخرى
دخلت على مكة الأصل أنه سندها علمي صوفي
ثم بعد ذلك وجدت طريقها إلى الحوانيت، وغيره
سمُّوها الشاذلية، من فين جاءت التَّسمية؟
أيش عرّف واحد في تُخوم الصُّمان
والربع الخالي والعراق، في بادية بالشاذلي؟
ما يعرف
لكن هذا أثر من النوع الـ...
وهذا يُدل أنها جات من الحواضر
الحواضر كان فيها مراكز الطوائف الصُّوفية في ذاك الزمان
وهذا الدليل أنها خرجت من الحاضرة إلى البادية
لكن البادية اللي أدخلت الدَّلة إلى الحاضرة
«الشَّطي» يقول أن الدَّلة من الدَّلال
رُبمَّا
رُبمَّا؟
لأنه، أصلًا ما في كتاب في المكتبة السعودية أعتقد إلَّا كتاب...
الله يعطيني اسمه
«تكريم الدلّة العربية» لـ«تغلب الدوسري»
كتاب جديد، جميل جدَّا
فما في أحد المعاجم تكلم عن الدَّلة
فبعضهم يقول هي من الدَّلال
وبعضهم يقول هي من الدَّل
وبعضهم يقول من الدِّلالة
لكن كلها تَحتمل لا بأس
فالدَّلة من البادية؟
هي دخلت من الـ...
هي من الحاضر تطورت ثم دخلت إلى البادية
ثم دخلت صارعت الأواني الفُخارية اللي كانت تُصنع في...
بالمناسبة، الدَّلة ما كانت معروفة في مكة قبل ستين سنة
ستين سنة، أيش كان معروف؟
في كتاب مكة في القرن الرابع عشر الهجري
«محمد عمر رفيع» رحمة الله عليه
وقتها كان يؤرِّخ وهو في حياة الملك «عبدالعزيز»
وبعده، بعد وفاته
فكان يقول أنه دخلت علينا قهوة الدَّلة
بعد استتباب الحكم السعودي، وانضمامه
بدأت تدخل، يعني هي ثقافة دخلت عليها
فصار على الثقافة اللي كانت موجودة اللي هي أيش؟
الماجور اللي هو الجَبَنَة اللي هو الفَخَّار
وكانت قهوة أهل مكة سوداء
ما كانوا يعرفون، إي القهوة سوداء
فجاءت غلبت هذه القهوة، اللي كانت وقتها من نجد
واستطابها الناس، وشاعت فيهم
فإذا تجي تَطُل فيها معقول جدًّا، ووارد جدًّا فخاريَّة
من فين جاءت الدلة؟ جاءت من العراق
من يهود العراق ابتداءً
وصار في أسماء معلمين عمرها 150 سنة
بأيش كانوا يطبخوها أوَّل؟
كانوا يطبخوها في هذه الأواني الفخارية الكبيرة
أو القدور، قُدور النحاس الكبيرة
من وين جاءت إذا كان في مكة شقراء
عفوًا سوداء من وين جاءت الشَّقراء؟
وعادةً تُنسب الشَّقراء للشاذلية
فهل الشاذلي هو من طبخها شَّقراء؟
اللي أعرفه أنها وجدت بجميع أنواع حمساتها
في القرن التاسع الهجري
فمنهم يقولها «النَّاشري»
فمنهم إلى الحال المُسوِّد مائلٌ، ومنهم إلى تَجحيمه ما تزيّل
تَجحيم اللي هو التَّحميص، كان اسمه التَّجحيم من الجَحيم
فكن هشًّا...
يقول فكن وسطًا لتربح مأكلة
يقول: لا تخليها لا غامقة، ولا فاتحة
مثلًا، هذه مدرسته
ومع ذلك، ذكر أنه في ناس يحبونها فاتحة
وفي ناس يحبونها غامقة
مسألة ليش أنتشرت؟
الناس يضعون فرضيَّة، أنه كلما اتجهت إلى الشمال من اليمن
وصعد إلى الشمال ستجدها تغمَق
رُبَّما، لكن ما كان هذا الوضع سابقًا
كانت القهوة الشَّهيرة، القهوة السَّوداء
بعدين بدأ التفاوت لمَّا سَرت
وهذه إشكالية الإضافات، القهوة السعودية كيف نشأت؟
من فين جاءت المضافات؟
ليش تجد أقوام عندهم إضافات؟
ببساطة، يجيك واحد يقول لك أنه هي ذوقيَّة
هي صح ذوقيَّة، إن كان لها عِلَّة قبل أن تصبح ذوقيَّةً
لمَّا حصل الخلاف حول حكم القهوة
حُرّمت لأربعة أشياء لمَّا حُرّمت
حُرّمت لإسكارها، وهذا باطل
وحرّمت لإضرارها، وهذان سببان ذاتيّان في نفسها
وسببان عرضيّان، اللي هم هيئة شُربها
والاختلاط فيها، وأنه ما يحدث في بيوت القهوة
الإسكار باطل، فبقي الإضرار
قالوا ليش الإضرار، ما معناه؟
قال: إذا كان الإنسان مزاجه، وطبع نفسه بارد يابس
الطب القديم، والقهوة باردة يابسة فيضره ذلك
قال ماشي
تحرم عليه
كمثل صاحب السُّكري
يحرم عليه العسل إذا أكله، لأنه قد يؤدِّي إلى تهلكة
فقال: واحد، نحتاط لذلك بتعديل طبعها
كيف تعديل طبعها؟
البارد اليابس
تُعدِّل طبعه يا أنك تخلي البرودة هذه نوع من الحرارة
أو تخلي هذه اليُبوسة نوع من الرطوبة
بإضافة ما يُعدِّل طبعها
هذا موجود في مخطوط ذكرته، ووضعت هذه النظرية
أن الأصل لمَّا كان الإشكال طبِّي فقهي
فأضافوا لها الزَّنجبيل يُعدل طبعها
بعدين استساغوا الإضافات
تختفي العلَّة الأولى، وتنسلك في الممارسة
فما أحد يسأل ليش انضاف؟ عجبتني القهوة
طيب تدري، خلينا نضيف عليها هيل
خلينا نضيف عليها قرنفل
خلينا نضيف عليها حليب
خلينا نضيف عليها سكر، وهكذا تصبح مسألة ذوقيَّة
والله احنا نشربها بكذا
وأنتم تشربوها بهذا النوع من البهارات، واحنا لا، نحبها سادة
فيصير لك خلاف على مستوى بسيط
على مستوى ذوقي نسبي
بينما هو الأصل أنه كانت هذه
أو النظرية على الأقل اللي أنا اللي ارتاح لها
ودرستها في المقدمة
ثم صارت القهوة السعودية
قبل؟
قبل
لا، ما أدري إذا هي مع هذا المدخل ولّا لا
بس اللي هو ودِّي أعرف أنواع الفناجين
اللي هو الهيف والكيف والضيف، وغيره
ولِمَا أو كيف ظهرت هذه الطقوس، خصوصًا عند البادية؟
فنجان الـ...
الفناجين في الثقافة السعودية
فنجان الهيف والكيف والسيف والضيف
الهيف هو فنجان الاختبار، وهذا قديم
أقدم من أنه يكون عمره ستين أو سبعين سنة
لا، هو أقدم من ذلك
يختبر جودتها؟
إي، يختبر جودتها، ومشكلة الاغتيالات السياسية أول
لازم تطمنه، شيخ قبيلة جاء عن شيخ قبيلة
يا أخي أتخلص منه بسم، وانتهينا
فلازم أنت تشرب حتى يتطمن أنك تشرب بنفس الفنجان
لأنه راح يشرب بنفس الفنجان بالمناسبة
ما كان فيه تنوع الفناجين هذا
تشرب من نفس الفنجان
قالك تستشرب من نفس الكأس
بس كانوا يظنوا أن المجالس كانت فيها هذا الرَّفاه
وفناجين وفي قهوجي لا يا حبيبي
هو فنجان يدور على الجميع
بعض الأثرية كان عنده أكثر من فنجان
وإلَّا، ما في أصلًا موجب لمسألة أنه تُدِير الكأس بينهم
ليش تُدِير الكأس ما تجيب له كاسة؟
ما فيه
في ناس كذا يجي يقيس الماضي يقرأه بصورة معولمة حاضرة اليوم
غريب يا أخي، كأن الموضوع بسيط
لا، الرَّفاه اللي أنت تعيشه ما هو موجود
الحاصل...
مسألة هز الفنجان برضو كان لها سبب سياسي
قال أنه بعد سقوط الدِّرعية
بداية نشأة الدولة السعودية الثانية كان هناك نوع من التَّربص
وربما كان في الدولة السعودية كذلك
نوع من التَّربص بالدولة السعودية
فكانوا يحرصون أن القهوجي يكون أصم ما يسمع
فتكفيه هذه الإشارة على معنى إملأ، وزِدني
وهذه الإشارة
توقف
اللي هي أنك تضع يدك على الـ...
راح هذا الأصم
شاف له وظيفة ثانية أو توفي إلى الله
بقيت العادة كما هي
ليش يطُقَّها؟
ليش يطق الفنجان بالدَّلة؟
ليش؟
لأنه ينبهك
أنت تكون تتكلم بحاجة فإذا دقّها
تنتبه لأنه التفت، وخُذ الفنجان لأنه قد يحرق يده
فهي حيلة مؤدّبة جميلة يعطي...
قائمة كذا تحس فيها واحد هندسها هندسة
وربما يكون هذا صحيح
أنه شوف جاتك من أفق يهتم بالرُّسوم، وشوية طقوس
ولا تقدّم بينك، وبينه ثلاث خطوات
لا تقول يا هيه أو يا فلان هاك الفنجان
تقول له سم أو تفضل
فيه نوع من الأدب الجميل في هذا الطقس
وينبغي المحافظة عليه
طيب، هل كانت القهوة هي الشيء الوحيد
اللي الرجل يقوم على...
هو اللي يطبخها، ويحضرها بنفسه؟
هذا كان العُرف، نعم
وليش كانت القهوة بذاتها مو بقية الأشياء؟
ليش أخذها الرجال؟
والله...
اللي فيه مُقاربة، يعني ما عندك جواب
أولًا لطبيعة المشيخة العلمية، والمشيخة القبليَّة
ثم وجدت في هذا الـ...
واحد يقول لك طيب، ما فيه صوفيات؟
بلى فيه ما
ما يُصلِّين الليل؟
بلى موجود
بس احنا نتكلم عن الحكم الأغلبي
يجيك واحد يقول لك القهوة ما شربتها النساء
ليش، عشان ما ورد الخبر؟
عدم الوجدان، لا يعني العدم
لكن الحكم الأغلبي، والأكثري نعم ما ورد أنه...
لكن ما كانوا يَشرَبنَها أو كانت محرمة؟ لا
بَلى كُنَّ يشربنها
لكن لما ارتبطت بنوع من الضيافة و...
فأنها في منظومة الضيافة العربية، الرجل اللي يستقبل الضيوف
طب لو ما كان؟
تجي تسمع في قصة البادية أنه كانت تستقبل الزوجة الضيوف
لكن تعطيهم الدِّلال والبُن والحَطب والذَّبيحة
تجمع هذا القول، مع هذا القول تجد أنه ما في إشكال
يقول لك القهوة جاءت في ثقافة ذكورية
تاريخ بكبره إذا بتأخد بهذا المقاس الذكوري
بس حتى الدكتور «سعد الصويان» يقول أنه الشاي للحريم
الشَّاي مُتأخر
مُتأخر كم؟
مرَّة مُتأخر متى...
تتكلم على 110 سنوات ربما...
قبلها ما عرفته الجزيرة العربية؟
لا، أوَّل دولة دَخَلها الشَّاي المغرب
1195-1190 هجرية
1204-1240 تُوفِّي «محمد ابن عبدالله بن إسماعيل»
اللي في زمانه عُرفت العشبة هذه، وأخذها من أوربا
احنا دخل لنا من العراق
1260 يؤرخ «عبدالقدوس الأنصاري» رحمة الله عليه
في كتابه «موسوعة تاريخ مدينة جدة»
أنه دخل إلى ميناء جدة شُحنة شاي 1260
بس مش بالضرورة أنها دخلت بمعنى، أنها كانت سلعة تجارية عامة
دخلت لكن يمكن ما كان يعرفها أحد
من أين اكتسبت اسمها؟
من الميناء اللي صدر منه الشاي
كانت الصين تصدر عبر مينائين
ميناء برِّي مسك الخط هذا، اللي هو إيران إلى الهند إلى فارس
فتجي تلاقي أنه اسمه عندنا العرب والفرس والهنود
شاي
شاهي أو شاي
نسبةً إلى الميناء؟
نسبة إلى الميناء اللي هو كانت تصدر منه، فهي لغتين
اسمه «تشا»
لا، كانوا يُسموه الصينيين في ذيك الـ...
في لُغتين عامتين في الصين، وأكثر
لكن الماندراين كانوا يسموه «تشا»
«تَاي» اللغة الثانية اللي كانت تخرج بحرًا
ووصلت للبرتغال دخلت على فرنسا إلى هولندا إلى المغرب
دخلت باللفظة «تَاي»
فسموه «تي»
هم «تي» الأوربيين لكنَّه «تاي»
سموه «تي»
فأحنا أخذناه كما هو بالصِّيني، فشاي
شاي أو «شاهي» إلى آخره
و«شاه» بعضهم يقولوا حتى
فالشاهي حديث على الـ...
مرَّة يعتبر جديد فمسألة أنه هي كانت القهوة و...
رُبَّما لأنه في لهم قول مشهور أنه القهوة خَص، والشاي قَص
الشاي ما يُعتمَد فيه الترتيب إن ساد
لكن القهوة لا، لها التَّرتيب، ولها كذا
لأنها جايه من أُفق ثاني، والشاي جاي من أُفق ثاني الـ...
الشاي، دواء تحول لمشروب
بل أنه يقولوا، أنه اللي أدخله الكويت
رجل من أهل الزِّلفي، عام 1311 هجري
مثلًا، هذه مؤرِّخين الروايات الشفهيه في الكويت
لكن أعتقد أنه كان قبل ذلك
لكن، لعلَّه هو اللي أشاعه، وخلَّاه مشروب
تمام، الحين تلقى في على الشاي
الشاي قطعًا صيني، صح؟
الأشهر فيه أنه صيني، نعم
ووجد طريقه إلى اليابان وإلى الهند
الهند بالمناسبة جديد فيها الشاي
هو كان يُزرع بطريقة معينة
لكن، بريطانيا اللي جعلت من الهند أرض استزراع الشاي
بل أنها تغلبتها على الصين في إنتاج الشاي
وراحت لبنجلاديش ولسريلانكا، وحولتها لمزارع
عشان تتحكم في تجارته العالمية
كنت آكل قبل كم يوم، في مطعم تركي
قال لي بعطيك شاي تركي
قُلت: حبيبي، فأعطاني شاي
شاي ما فيه أي ابتكار، ولا أي فكرة
شاي، وسمَّاه شاي تركي
ولولا أنَّ الفكرة في بالي، لما استوقفني الحدث
يُزرع في تركيا
يُزرع في تركيا لكن، عادي أنه نُسب إلى تركيا
في هذا الـ...
القهوة التركية خُذها أوضح
لا، بس القهوة قول أنها لها طريقة معينة، وأنه الناس...
لا، القهوة التركية هي القهوة المصرية
بذات الطريقة؟
نعم
فأصلها مصري
تُرجعها للشام ثم لمصر ثم لمكة
تطور اللي حصل هذا للقهوة، في مصر
ليش سموها تركية؟
ببساطة لأنه عرفها الغرب عن طريق تركيا
ما هذا؟ هذه قهوة تركية
ما هو اجتهدوا الأتراك و...
وسموها تركية؟
لأنك، تروح الآن تركيا تطلب قهوة تقول له قهوة
تقول قهوة تركية
فسواءً الحين عندك القهوة التركية
اللي نرجع إلى أنَّ أصلها مصري تُسمى قهوة تركية
ولا يُزرع البُن عندهم أصلًا، ولا الوصفة وصفة تركية
لا الأثنتين تركية ومع ذلك تسمى تركية، واحد
إثنين، أنَّ الشاي زُرع عندهم أو ما زُرع عندهم
لأنه يمكن اللي جابها حطَّها «ليبتون» ما أعرف
لكنَّه أسماه شاي تركي، والناس ما عندها مشكلة معها
وجود القهوة السعودية
ووزارة الثقافة أعلنت العام الماضي أنَّه عام القهوة السعودية
أصبح في هذا الإشكال
لمَ للسعودية الحق في أنها تقول أن عندها القهوة السعودية؟
وعندها هذه الطبخات الخاصة في...
وطريقة وصفات خاصة بالقهوة، وهي من أصل الجزيرة العربية
واللي تُشكل السعودية البقعة الجغرافية الأكبر
صحيح
ويستزرع فيهان سواءً في جيزان أو عسير أو الباحة أو الرياض حتى
طبعًا في محميات بس...
فيزرع ويطبخ ومنذ الأزل
فليش نستنكر أنها تكون في قهوة سعودية؟
أعتقد الاستنكار هو نوع من المفاجأة، مبدئيًّا
تجي تسأل سؤال هل في قهوة سعودية؟
بيقول لك في، وما في باعتبارين
أنت في النهاية عشان لا نصير نعيد نفس الكلام اللي قلناه في البداية
القهوة السعودية باعتبار أنه هي هذه الوصفة
هي الأشيع في هذا القطر؟ نعم
أنه ما تُستخدم خارجه؟ قال لك، لا
هي الأشيع ؟ نعم
طوَّروا فيها؟ نعم
تعرف إشكالية مصطلح القهوة السعودية؟
أنه يلغي التعدد فقط
أي تعدد تقصده؟
الآن أنت عندك كم وصفة في السعودية للقهوة؟
قول خمسة عشر، شيء؟
مثلًا هذا المُنتخب
ولّا ممكن كل إنسان له وصفة
لكن خلّينا نقول المنتخبات اللي يمكن تسطيّع أنك تُمايز بين نوع، ونوع
خلِّلينا نوصلها إلى، يا أبوي خمسة
اللي هم اقترحوها مع المناطق
تجد أنه القهوة الشمالية
بدون مضافات اللهم الهيل والحمسة غامقة
فيها حمضية عالية، وقوامها ثقيل
والقهوة الجنوبية خفيفة وشقراء، ومليئة بالبهار
هذا، وهذا سعودي من حيث الأصل
لكن أنا لو بطلب هذه، وهذه
أسمِّي قهوة سعودية، وتجيني مرَّة كذا، ومرَّة كذا
أو مرَّة قهوة الشمال والوسطى...
الآن أتكلم وظيفيًّا
انتهينا من جزء أنه لك الحق أن تسميها بلا شك
يخدم الثراء الثقافي؟ أختلف أو أتفق
لا، أنا برأيي أنَّه لا يخدم
ليش؟
لأنه راح تُلغي هذه التَّفريعات، والتَّشعيبات
راح تُلغيها مع الوقت
بس ليش بالضرورة يُلغيها؟
يوم كُنَّا نقول عليها قهوة عربية، أعذرني
ما كان في هذا الإشكال حاضر
نعم، احنا نقصد بالقهوة العربية النجدية
لكن لمَّا تبغى قهوة الشمال؟ أنت تسميها شمالية
وتسميها جنوبية
لا، بس لمَّا نقول...
لا، ما لك لوا
ليش؟
في البيت عندنا، أنا من الجنوب تحديدًا من عسير
ففي الجنوب فيه تعدد برضو
صحيح
فحتى أنت اللي جالس تسويه الحين فيه هذا...
فيه أنك جالس تُحجِّمنا، وتحط أنها كلها وصفة واحدة
أنا ماني في محاضرة، أنت تبغى تُفهم الفكرة لا أكثر
أفهم
ولّا أعلم...
قصدي في عسير رُحت، يقول: أعطني قهوة عربية
ما يتوقع مني أني بجيب له قهوة غير القهوة حقَّت البيت
صح، لأنك قلتها في البيت
لأنك قلتها في عسير، هذا الإشكال
ولو جيت إنت عندي، وأنا الآن أسكن الرياض
جيت البيت، وطلبت قهوة عربية أو قدَّمت القهوة العربية
ستقدّم على الطريقة اللي تسويها أمي، وهي قهوة
هذا الأصل
هذا الأصل الطبيعي، نعم
فعادي ما في بأس بأن القهوة السعودية هي كل هذا
لا بأس
فعادي أنك تطلبها، وفجأة تتفاجئ
الآن نفس الفكرة يجيك آدمي من عسير، وآدمي من الشمال
بالنهاية سعودي
لكن، هذا لا يثلغي كون أنه عنده ميِّزة
شيء يفرقه عن غيره، شيء لهجي أو شيء لوني
هذا نقدر نتكلم، لا نخلط بين المستويين
هي موجودة من حيث الأصل؟ نعم
لكن، في نوع من اللي هو...
جبريَّة هذا الموضوع يعني يُفرض، ويُلزم ماشي
راح يُؤتي أُكُله بعد سنوات
بس ما في جبرية طبعًا؟
لا، هو ما في جبرية
هو أقول لك في ناس تتلقف كل شيء بهذا المبدأ
وأنت تتصارع مع أي شيء
فقهوة سعودية، واللي يقول عربية هذا فيه...
أهدأ
قول شمالية وقول جنوبية وقول عربية وقول سعودية
أهدأ، أنت قاعد...
المصطلح راح يخدم أيش؟
أيش تبغى، ما فهمتك؟
يلَّا، أعطيني قهوة سعودية، ما فهمتك؟
أعطيك شمالية ولّا جنوبية، ما فهمتك؟
ولّا أعطيك اللي أسويها في البيت؟
والمفترض أنه يصير أيش؟
يصير الإطار شخصي وذاتي
فنطلع من المعيارية اللي هم...
نطمح لمعيارية معينة بالقهوة، ونرجع ذاتي
فتقول لي أعطيني قهوة سعودية، وأسوي لك اللي أسويه
ما قصدت هذا؟ قلت: والله لا أعرف إلَّا هذا
ونقعد ندخل في جدل فلسفي
عميق كذا سنوات، واحنا لسَّه القهوة تبرد
طيب ممتاز
فاحنا الحين نتفق أنه ما فيه إشكال في مصطلح القهوة السعودية
لا يمكن أن يكون هناك إشكال
فالقهوة السعودية...
في تحفظات على بعض التطبيقات رُبَّما
مثل أيش؟
ما في إشكال
هي هذه مسألة أنه وجود القهوة السعودية وهذا الإسم الجامع
لا يلغي وجود هذه الثقافات المنسدلة
ما أحد يقول بهذا بس...
إذا ما أتفقنا...
ما أحد يقول بهذا، لكن واقعًا
شوف، نتيجة من نتائج...
لو أنه وزارة الثقافة جاءت، وقالت:
أن القهوة السعودية هي ربع ملعقة هيل، وربع ملعقة ما أدري أيش
بيبسي صارت
واختاروا وصفة مثلًا نجد
لا، صار عندي هذا الإشكال معك
يعني لا أتفقت مع هذا الإشكال
أنه تحديد نوع ما هيه القهوة السعودية
لكن القهوة السعودية هي بُن
حتى الوصفة، وحتى القهوة النجدية نفسها
تختلف من بيت لبيت صحيح؟
صحيح
معيارية الطعام بشكل عام كمبدأ، لا يمكن ضبطها
أساسًا، حتى لو قلت هي...
راح يجيك واحد يقول لك طيب، ماشي
لن التزم بهذه الوصفة، وأزيد رُبع معلقه هيل، وما صارت سعودية
لا، شوف لو صارت بهذه الحديَّة، والضَّرفية
راح يجيك واحد يقول يعني أزيد قرامين، وما صارت سعودية؟
صارنا في هذه اللي هي...
لكن بالعموم نتكلم، فيه أشياء...
ثقافيًّا، قد يُفرض اسم، وقد لا يُفرض اسم
قد تجد أنه الاسم يأخذ مجراه بسبب ظرف خارج أصلًا  عن الـ...
زي ما حصل مع القهوة التركية
هم ما سموها تركية
وأنه من مصلحة القهوة
نعم
ومن مصلحة القهوة السعودية
في كل الحالتين سواءً مُزارعين أو حتى في الوصفة ذاتها
نعم
أنَّها تنتشر، أنه عادي أنها بدأت...
يعني اليوم ما قبل عام القهوة السعودية
وما قبل أن يكون في هذا الترويج لمفهوم القهوة السعودية
كنت عادي تروح المطار تدخل صالة الفرسان
ما تلقى أصلًا إلَّا كلها كابتشينو، وإسبريسو
اليوم تلقى القهوة السعودية ثابت
مقاهي برضو بعضها صار يبيع
فإعادة إيجادها إلى المشهد التجاري
أحس أنه ساهم في هذا، وساهم في زراعة الـ...
الاستثمار الأكثر في زراعة البُن في المناطق السعودية
أعتقد العام الثقافي يزامن لكن، استراتجيًّا
البُن موضة من قبل وما بعد
القهوة عالمية من زمان
لا، بس أتكلم على هذا الـ...
نعم ساهم
سواءً في استزراع البُن داخل السعودية
صحيح أنه في مبادرة من «أرامكو»
2016 بدأت
لكنه كانت على استحياء لو تلقى...
أتذكر رحت مرَّة الدَّاير في جيزان
وكان يادوب عدد المستفيدين قليل
إي ما تجاوز 300 شخص
كانوا خمسة وستين مُزارع
هذا الاستثمار الحين في الشركة السعودية للقهوة
في عندك عام القهوة كذا هذه الـ...
أحس أنه جالس...
صح، وأنا كنت أقول كلمة
عام القهوة هذا بدايته لا تعني بداية مشاريع القهوة في السعودية
ونهايته لا تعني انتهاء مشاريع القهوة في السعودية
أنت قاعد تتعامل مع عام ثقافي
وله أن يأخذ أكثر من سمة
لكن العمل على البُن
أنت قاعد تشتغل مع شجرة تنمو، وتنتج
وعندك ظُروف سياسية، وعندك ظُروف جيولوجية
وعندك ظُروف مُناخية، وعندك تجارة، وعندك طلب وعرض
للتَو بدأ الموضوع، حتى مبادرة «أرامكو»
إن وجدت في 2016 فالآن السنة هذه، والعام تبدأ تأخذ ثمارها
لأنه لو استزرعوها تحتاج من ثلاثة إلى أربع سنوات حتى تبدأ تنتج لك
ومن سبعة إلى عشر سنوات تبدأ الشجرة تعطيك المحصول الأفضل
لأن نقول عام القهوة السعودية في نهاية العام
المفترض أن نكون في مَصافي الدول
وهذا شيء مُتعذر
يعني، هل تستطيع منافسة البرازيل في الإنتاج؟
أرضهم بالغلط لو ضربت بمعزقٍ في الأرض سال نهار
وأنت اليوم تشتكي من مسألة الشُّح
وعندك تحدي حقيقي مسألة شُح المياه
طيب مع ذلك، تستطيع أن تأخذ تموضع جيِّد؟
أيش تقصد؟
اهتم بالنوعية
أنت تقف على إرث قديم
أنت الجزيرة موطن البُن
تقدر تبتز العالم بهذا لكن وظفه بشكل كويس
شلون التوظيف المثالي؟
قف على هذا الإرث
واستجلب...
تجد أنت موقعك الجغرافي ممتاز
اجلب بورصة العالم أنها تصير عندك
مركز دراسة البُن العالمي
أعد هذا الوهج اللي كان في الجزيرة العربية، حتى اليمن
تستطيع أنه أنت ثقافيًّا تُنمي هذا الموضع في اليمن
تَشارك، الحدود السياسية ليس بالضرورة حدود ثقافيَّة
اعملها، أنت عندك المسوغ التَّاريخي
أعطيك على سبيل مثال 18% من إنتاج البُن في العالم من البرازيل
مين بعده؟
ألمانيا
ألمانيا ما تزرع بُن، كيف ثاني أكبر مُصدر؟
بعد البرازيل، وكولومبيا كيف ثاني أكبر مُصدر؟
ثاني أكبر مُصدر
كيف؟
يأخذ البُن، يعالجه ويحمصه ويضبطه ويبيعه عليك
طيب، أنت تقدر تعمل هذا
أنت أقرب من المانيا لكثير من الدول المستهلكة
اللي المانيا تبيع لها
صحيح
أنت تأخد 70% من المحصول اليمني
اليمن 70% من محصولها يجي للسعودية
أنت قاعد تخدم أصلًا الاقتصاد اليمني بهذا
إنتاجك للبُن يحتاج إلى سنوات بلا شك
والمفترض أنه احنا نكون متواضعين مع هذه الحقيقة
لا بأس، اليمن من 100% المُحتكر الوحيد للبُن في العالم
الآن اليمن أقل من 1%
أنت اليوم إنتاجك متواضع
100 طُن بعضهم قال 650 في أقصى التَّقديرات
طيب، يُمكن
طبعًا، استهلاك في السعودية ستين ألف طن
استيراد ثلاثة وسبعين ألف طن
وبعضهم وصلوه ثمانين ألف طن
تتكلم أنه مايغطي حتى كفاية ذاتية
أيش الإشكال؟
أنه الناس لما تجي تجيها الرسالة هذه والدعاية حق البُن والـ...
يظن أنه أنت قاعد تتكلم عن أنه الآن، أنا في جاهزيتي القصوى
الرسالة وصلت
فجاء طَالع ما في السوق بُن سعودي
وإن وُجد، يُوجد بشكل كذا فلكلوري مُعين
طيب، لا هذا هو فهم أن البُن يحتاج إلى وقت
لكن الرسالة جاءته فيها شُحنة جميلة
احنا هذه مسألة اللي هي الوزنية البسيطة
نؤمن أنه محتاجين جُهد، وعندنا تحدي في مسألة الزراعة
وقصَّة كيف أخلي الناس تزرع البُن؟
الناس تُهرب من الزراعة
تكاليفها عالية، وتعب وإرهاق
ما عندي ماء، بس عندي إرث
الإرث هذا يعطيني هذا الصبر والـ...
اللي أتحمل به كيف أجيب حلول؟
لأنه أنا ما أعز الله، ودولة قررت
لا، في إرث في ثقافة
هو يُشكِّل صُلب منظومة الضيافة عندك عامودها الأساسي
ما تزعل لو ما عشِّيتك، بس تزعل لو ما قهويتك
والفنجان قامت عليه حقوق، وقامت مُقاصَّات ومحاكمات
لا، ما هو شيء سهل في ثقافتك
لا يمكن أنه تسحب الفنجان من المنظومة، والمنظومة تكون بخير
لا، لن تكون بخير
فأنت تتكلم أنه أنت عندك أرث ثقافي تستاهل الوقوف عليه
تقول يا جماعة الخير أنا...
من هذه الأرض حصل هذا الشيوع، والذُّيوع
وابتُكر المقهى أول مرَّة، وحصل...
لمَّا وصلتهم ترى ضافوا عليها التِّقانة الغرب
لمَّا وصلتهم القهوة طوَّروا الحمَّاصة، وما هي بعيدة
وطوروا نفس الأباريق اللي كانت تُطبخ فيها، ما هي بعيدة
لكن لمَّا حصل عندهم العصر الذهبي والصناعي
دخلت أدوات القهوة من جُملة ما دخل في التحسينات الصناعية، وابتكرت فيه
بعدها بدأت بالنار بعدين بالغاز بعدين بالكهرباء، إلى آخره
فهو الفضيلة عنده في التِّقانة، لا أكثر
أما مسألة من عرَّف الناس بها، ومن أضاف إليها
من حسّن وصفاتها، ومن عرف الناس بالتحميص؟ أنت
أسيب هذا كله وأجي أمسك في آخر حتَّة كذا
آخر ستين أو سبعين أو ثمانين سنة
وأقول من هنا بدأ تاريخ القهوة، ليش؟
يا أخي خلاص إنهزام
يا أخي والله أنت واقف على شيء ممتاز، ورائع جدَّا
شوية تضبيط، وشوية كمان لا تبيع نفسك بزيادة
أنت واقف على شيء حقيقي
خليه يلتفت إلى هذه الثقة مش إلى أنه أنا بحاول أكون...
حتى يصير منتج القهوة السعودية موجود في رُفوف العالم
يحتاجوا إلى خطة، ما هو إلى صُراخ
تَصل، اللي وصَّل الببسي والشَّاهي
واللي وصَّل مشروبات المتَّة مثلًا
ما عُرف عندنا، ولا أفكر اللي شربها أول مرة أنها توصل عندنا
بنوع من التخطيط، وبنوع من الدَّهاء
تستطيع أنك توصلها
مسئلة أنه إشمئزاز منها طعمها في البداية
كُلَّنا طعم الإسبريسو ما عجبنا أول مرَّة
ولا القهوة العربية أو السعودية عجبتنا أول مرة
ما  أحد استساغها، طيب ماذا حصل اليوم؟
والله لا أستطيع أن أكمل يومي بدونها
صحيح
طيب ما هي المسألة هذه
خلاص دام عرفت أنه هذه النتيجة
أعمل على تسويق هذا المنتج بأنه أنا أعمل منه الكفاية في نفسي
أعمل الكفاية، وأحسنه، وأحسن طعمه وخواصه
وأهتم بالنَّوعية، بنما مثلًا
بنما ترى أنتاجها متواضع من البُن، متواضع جدًّا
بس مشهورة لأجل جودة السُّلالات اللي فيها
بنما قيشا وكمارة والقيشا
القيشا هذه السلالة اللي رفعت بناما في نهاية التسعينيات
يعني أقول لك أنه مو صعبة
عام ثمانية وتسعين أو سبعة وتسعين
ثم...
و2015 خلاص بدأت تأخذ الجوائز، والدنيا، والقيشا
دخلنا في 2015-2016 وكوبا النُّخبة كانوا يسموه
طيب المسألة ما هي بعيدة 2015 قبل أمس
ثمانية وتسعين قبل قبل امس، يعني الواحد يستطيع
ما هو...
نأخذ من العالم أفضل ما فيه، وندمجه به
خاصَّةً أنا مُتأكد أنه راح نطلع بوصفات أخرى
وأحس حتى لو أنه نبحث في جوانب مختلفة
سواءً الحين عندنا الجانب التجاري، وهو مهم جدًّا
والجانب الزراعي برضو هو مهم
على أكثر من شكل سواءً ثقافي أو اقتصادي
كذلك حتى الجوانب الثقافيَّة، والجوانب الأكاديمية
كيف برضو نقدر نزيد من غزارة الإنتاج الثقافي الأكاديمي
اللي أحس أغلب العالم كله بيقدر يتفق معك
إذا أنت قدرت تطلعه على شكل مُحكَّم
صح
بس هذه تتطلب جُهد
أيش أُصولك؟
أيش أصول ثقافة القهوة؟
ثُراث القهوة وينه؟
مخطوط
واحد يقول لك أنا والله ودِّي أبحث بس ما...
بملقط تأخذه من مكتبات العالم و...
وتجي تسألني أنت عن القهوة السعودية
كان نفسي حاجة
جهد واحد بس يوجّه بعيدًا عن الإعلان
إلى تأسيس قاعدة للباحثين
مَسرد ثَبت بأسماء المراجع اللي ذُكر فيها القهوة
وتتكفل واحدة من مراكز الأبحاث
ولّا واحدة من المكتبات الوطنية بجلبها
ببريد الكتروني تجيب كل هذا
انتهى العام
مافي
أنت بس تبغى تقول يا جماعة سيبوا الشغل قضية ثانية
ييجوا ناس يشتغلوا عليه
لذلك كان واحدة من همومي أنه أنا أخرج هذا الموضوع
أشتغل عليه كله؟ ما أقدر أكذب عليك
طلِّعه لو اسمه، خلِّي اللي بعدك يجي أوه فيه مخطوط كذا
بأخذه من المكتبة بس، لو تُحيل إلى اسمه فقط
ثم بعد ذلك اشتغل عليه، وعلى مراحل
أمَا أنك تتبغى كل شيء يصير في سنة واحدة
أو في عام واحدة أو حتى في سنتين ثلاثة؟
صعب، واقعيًّا صعب
أنه اللي يُطبخ بهدوء تراه يُستدام
لا تصدم الناس تقدر توصل لنفس النتيجة بس بهدوء، فعلًا
كُنت أتمنى هذا الجهد أنه يصير المكتبة المخطوطة
عملت، وما زلت أعمل إلى الآن
على أنِّي أصنع مَسرد بأسماء المخطوطات في التراث العربي
اللي موجود منها أُحيل إليه، واللي ما هو موجود منها...
حتى ولله لو يكون في شيء
بما أنَّ القهوة واضح أنها شيء مهم بالنسبة لوزارة الثقافة
أنه سواءً من خلال هيئة الطَّهي أو أي من الهيئات الموجودة
مركز أبحاث مثختص بهذا الـ...
يا سلام
المكان فقط، في كيف أنِّي أنا أصل للقهوة بكل اللغات
وأني أسردها بالشكل العلمي الأكاديمي اللي...
أنا عندي نظرية بوصلها للعالم عندي فكرة بقولها
العالم راح يقول لي، يا حبيبي ما دليلك على هذا؟ ببساطة
قول لي والله هذا اللي عندي، موجود بس يحتاج له جهد
يحتاج له نوع حتى من المرونة اللي خليني أقول لك التاريخيَّة
يا أخي تصطدم أحيانًا بشغلات ما تحبها على مستوى الشخصي
والله القهوة الصوفية اللي...
يا أخي خلِّي خلافك مع الصوفية لما تتكلم على موضوع...
اللي جعلها بهذه القيمة عندك هي
وكونها ولدت في الحاضنة الصوفية
ما نقول لك روح صير صوفي، ولّا حب الصوفية
ولّا رضاؤك بما فعلوا بمعنى...
خذه ببساطة
ما نبغى ننسبها إلى قُطر أو نوع معين أو شتلة معينة
تجاوز هذه المسألة الثقافية، تجاوزها
وراح تجد لك مثلًا على سبيل المثال
من الذي أول من أشار إلى استزراع البُن في السعودية؟
أين وُجدت؟ ما في مصدر سعودي يقول هذا
مصدر تركي، عُثماني
يُؤرخ «حسين أفندي هزارفن»
في كتابه «تلخيص البيان» يقول: إنه تزرع في اليمن
في بداية جبال رَيمة ما يحاذي بيت الفقيه، صعودًا إلى جيزان
إشارة
موجود، لك في هذا العالم الحق فقُم
قُوم، ما تنتظر أحد يجي ينصفك من الخارج
والله تصدق يا أخي هذول يشتغلوا ما أحد راح ينصفك
على قولهم الكثير من الحق، ما يجي إلَّا بقليل من الباطل
هاوش، وخذ حقَّك بذراعك
إن شاء الله
بالعدل والإنصاف ولك
لك بالعدل والإنصاف ستجد ما يغني، وزيادة
وهو أفضل بآلاف المرات من أنك تقول فقط ولا تفعل
أنا بقول أن الحديث معك لا يُمل
وأنِّي مبسوط والله بقبولك الدعوة
الله يسعدك، والله الشرف لي
مبسوط بكل ما أنتجت، وبكتابك ديوان القهوة
الله يعطيك العافية
الله يعافيك، ويبارك فيك
وشاكر لك حبيبي عبدالرحمن، على هذه الفرصة
شكرًا لك
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لأيمن الحمَّادي في إعداد الحلقة
وهَّاب موسى في التصوير
وضياء الدين المدني في الهندسة الصوتية
عبدالمجد العطَّاس في التلوين
هذا فنجان أحد المنتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر، والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل، القاكم
طبعًا في أسئلة فلسفية نأخذها
إي تفضل، اخنقني
أيش دور الـ...
أنا عندي سؤال والله ذاك اليوم كانت عنده الشجاعة أنه
عيد السؤال معليش
لا، مو أنه عنده سؤال
شفت السؤال اللي أنت سحبت علي؟ ما جاوبتني
اللي...
ما جاوبته، ما يتجاوب
هل عندك أي شيء نقطة ما غطيناها تحس أنها مرَّة مُهمة؟
والله جد عادي لا تستحي
خلاص بعد أيش؟
حتى ترى مصطلح التَّنمر، عجيب والله كيف صار مُتداول
إي مع أنه مُعجمي
مُعجمي، ما أحد يعرف أيش يعني تنمر
يعني كان في المعجم واحد من الأدباء استخدمه
فواحد أحال عليه، وواحد استخدمه يعني فجأة تلاقي...
يا أخي والله عجيب
والله رائع
عجيب مسألة أنه يا أخي لا تشتغل...
يعني اشتغل بدهاء، والله في بعض الأحيان
المُسوقين ذول جن، طبعًا أتكلم على التسويق بمعناه النفسي
اللي كانوا يشتغلوا عليه النفسانيين
كيف يُروج لك مصطلح؟
يُدخله في التَّداولية، يجيبه من المعجم ويدخله
ويجيب لك إياه في إعلانات، وأوقات مُعينة
تجدها وصلت، واستقرت في معجمك اليوم
تقدر توصل القهوة السعودية بهذه الطريقة
تقدر توصلها بهذه الطريقة
هل التنمر كلمة موجودة في المعجم من زمان، قديمًا؟
إي
اه فهي ما هي جديدة
أيش أصلها التنمر؟
هل هي ترجع لـ...
هل هي نفس التَّنمر؟
أيش يلا خَلَّه سؤاله لا يخاف الحين
هل هي ترجع للنمر، نقدر نرجعها لنمر؟
ليش النمر؟ في حيوانات أشرس
أنت افترض أنه فيه علاقة بين النمر والـ...
لا، النمر لأنه ياكلك فيعني...
ترى هو مُتنمر بالدرجة الأولى
لو كانت التأسد برضو شغَّاله
الحقيقة نفسها اللغوية، وحقيقة الوضع
اللي يخدمها الاستخدام
صارت تنمر يعني يجي واحد يقول لك
التفيل ولّا التثور ما تفهمها، لكن التنمر
طبعًا هذا على فرضه أنه هي أساسًا مأخوذة من النمورة
اللي هي الحالة النمورية هذه، والسَّبُوعية
الله أعلم والله ما...
وهو مُتنمر بالدرجة الأولى طبعًا
هذا؟
مدرسة في التنمر
تيَّار ومذهب، ما شاء الله
هذه جازت لي تيَّار على مدرسة
مدرسة من الشغلات اللي تُعاب على...
هي مُترجمة مدرسة مأخوذة من من «سكول»
اللي هي يقول لك مثلًا، الفرانكفورية «سكول»
بمعنى تيَّار ومذهب، طيب أنت عندك كلمة مذهب
لكن لأنها ارتبطت تداوليًّا بمذاهب الفقهية والشرعية وكذا
في النحَّوية يقول لك التَّيار أو المدرسة الكوفيَّة أو البصرية
المذهب الكوفي، والمذهب البصري عادي
فأُخِذت الترجمة، وشاعت أكثر من المذهب
اللي كانت شغالة بالفعل من زمان و...
شوف تقول «أوريدي»
إي، دخل في الاستخدام
اللي يثقعد يستقعد على هذه الشغلات ترى انسان مو فاهم
والله؟
في شغلات تُدخل في لا وعيك اللغوي
لو جيت تقول لي...
أنا أنتبهت على نفسي، واستدركت على نفسي صح؟ بس حصلت
يجي يقول لك ها...
لا تجي هنا تعال لي في بُنية معجمي وكلامي، وتنتقدني فيه
قول لي أسلوبك مو عربي
بمعنى تبدأ بالفاعل قبل الفعل
بقول لك فيه أسلوب عربي يبدأ بالفعل قبل الفعل
لعلَّه بلاغية أو لنكتة بلاغية
لكن ما هو الأصل الشائع في الأسلوب
أكل أحمد التفاحة، في الإنقليزية أحمد أكل التفاحة
بس برضو العربي تقدر تأخذ...
تقدر؟
يعنيمثللما تأخذ من الفارسية في تقديم الـ...
لا، العربية فيها تقديم
لا، بس جزيل الشُّكر، كريم الـ...
لا، يوجد
موجود؟
إي يوجد في العربية
جزيل الشُّكر، مُضاف ومضاف اليه
ومن تقديم الصفة على الموصوف
هذه موجودة في لغة العرب
تقديم الصفة على الموصوف
وتقديم الفاعل لنكتة بلاغية، لأنك تريد أن تنببه على علو شأنه
الله خلق، الله نزَّل أحسن الحديث كتابًا
طيب يا أخي في هنا في القرآن
أن اكفر
لا
رحمة الله
إن «رحمت» الله جاءت بالتاء المفتوحة ما هو بالتاء المربوطة
«إن رحمت الله»
والله يا اخي علّلوها كثير علّل
كثير، أنت تنطقها أيش؟ بالوصل
بس لا
أيش اللي لا؟ لا تقيسهم على الحاضر
وليش؟
ليش؟ لأنه يقول لك هذه وجدت في استخدام ورسم العرب
إذًَا لا بأس، له وجاهه؟ له وجاهه
هو الشائع في الاستخدام؟ ليس الشائع اليوم في الاستخدام
طيب قبل ستين وسبعين سنة، 100 سنة؟ربَّما
تيَّار من التيارات في العراق مثلًا؟ ربَّما
في مصر؟ ربَّما
فإبقائها على ما هي عليه
أظن...
الله أعلم، أنا ما ودِّي أفتي قد مرت علي
لكن من زمان جدًّا،كان لهم تعليل أصحاب الرسم
لكن لها أصل، أنك تكتب ما تنطق هذا له أصل
هذا مخرج طيب لكل خطأ إملائي
لا إلَّا لو كنت واحد فزلوك
ترى والله مطاحنات حصلت، ما هو كل رأي له وجاهه على أي حال
وفي بعض الـ...
خليني أقول في بعض ما هو مَرجُوح وجوده يحجز عن فتنة أكبر
إبقي عليه عشان لا تُحدث فتنة
الناس تعودت تقرأ مثلًا كذا
تجي تغيرها؟ حُرِّف
يا عمِّي مو تحريف
في ناس إذا قرأت لهم بقراءة ولّا رواية، وَرش ولّا قَالون
بالصلاة وقال لك أنت تحرف كلام الله وخلاص
فتنة أنك أنت تقرأ بعض القراءات، فتنة
فلا خلاص أعتمد أهل الديار
حسبك وما تعرف
بس رهيب مرَّة، كان عندنا واحد في الحارة الفجريات يغير
عادةً الفجر لأن العَوام نايمين
يكون رايق الإمام، بس تفضل
أصلًا يخليك تتحمس أنك تصلي عند ذاك الإمام تحديدًا
كذا في فعاليَّة
لا بس الناس تبحث عن اللي الإمام صوته جيد
نعم
تسوي فعاليات
يا أخي وزاده بِسطَةً
زيادة في الخلق عند بعض المفسرين، هو حُسن الصوت
نعم والنبي، صلى الله عليه وسلم
ليش كان يحب يسمع من «أبو موسى الأشعري عبدالله»
يا أخي صوته حلو، أنت قاعد تمارس شيء طبيعي
الآن صار فيه كلام حُل، يعني الزيادة
احنا عندنا كذا، سبحان الله نوع من الـ...
ودَّك تتموضع في وسط التَّموضع اللي كان وسط التموضع في التًّطرف
خلاص الوسط وينه؟
لا، لكن تجي تقول يا أخي والله، سبحان الله
أحب أسمع الأناشيد
قال لك لكن ينبغي أنك تحذر من أنه تقد تأخذ...
يا سيدي سيبني أفرح شوية بس
يا أخي أحب اللي صوته حلو
رُبما، لكن القراءة بالمقامات أجازها البعض لكن قد تدخلك إلى...
يا ابن الحلال، يا أخي اكلمك في المباح مازلت
لازم يعطيك القيد
لازم يعطيك اللي ترى الحوش هذه السور يعني تراني منتبه لك
فيه هذا الأحساس لسه
يا حبيبي والله ما هو بالضرورة يكون من القوم إياهم
ولا بالضرورة من القوم إياهم، لا
في هذا الإحساس إجتماعي بالمناسبة ما له دخل بـ...
إجتماعي
تجيك هذه الوصاية اللي يا أخي بس
يا أخي مالك والله يا أخي مالك؟
خلِّي الواحد ينبسط
يا أخي أحب القرآن بالقراءات، وأحبه بالمقامات
يحملني يسعني قول: جزاك الله لا تقول لي الأقوال الثانية
يسعني أنت بينك، وبين نفسك
وبينك وبين اللي يرضي ربك وضميرك
يسعني قول؟ هيَّا حل عنِّي
بس، شكرًا
يجيك في مسألة خلافة يا سيدي
والله أنت...
وهي مُغالطه أنك تقول أنت أحسن منه
وفعلًا، هو ما هو احسن منه هذا
بالذات هذا اللي قاعد يناقشني في تويتر، ويناقشك في...
يعرف هو ذاك أنه...
قطعًا مو أفضل من اللي اختلف في زمان
صح
أي، فأنا وياك يعني يا تقلد فلان، وأنا أقلد فلان
وخليني يا أبوي كل واحد يصلح سيارته أيش رأيك؟
لا
أي خلاص، في حالة من أنه تحرمني أحقق ذاتي؟
يا حبيبي حقق ذاتك، في جامعات، وفي مدارس
وفي رياضة، وفي ممشى
حقق ذاتك عن طريق اللي هي القبضة على الجمرة
والله المُباح كثير، والخلاف ساعة
اللي هو أيش الفكرة البساطة؟ أنه ألغي فكرة سواغيَّة الخلاف ذا
عشان أضرب على فكرة أنه
لا إنكار في المسائل الاجتهادية، ومسائل الخلاف
وأصلًا ما هي مسئلة خلافية
ليه تقفل الباب من البداية؟
نطلع كذا كل مرة على السطح إلى أن نوصل عند...
قال الله: ومن الناس من يشتري لهو الحديث ليضل عن سبيل الله
ويصير مُفسِّر، وأصير مُفسِّر، سبحان الله، خلاص
القصة ذيك اللي جالسين على الجدار، هي كذا في النهاية
أنت يا مولانا تستطيع إعراب، بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم؟
لا، بس هي جاءت لك
يناقشك، حتى اللي يعرف إعرابه، ما هو بالضرورة أنه يعرف
لكن يا أخي خلِّينا شوي نحترم التخصصات
خلينا شوي نحترم كوننا أعوام
مُقلِّدين، صح التقليد على مراحل
نحترم أن فيه آراء معتبرة، ومختلفة
يا أخي إي والله، هنا نخسر بعض
ليش بتحقق ذاتك في هذه القضية؟
ليش تبغى تورِّيني...
فيها نوع من إشباع نفسي؟
أنا أبغى أورِّيك أنه أنا قابض على جمرة، أنت ما تستطع،ولا يمكن
زي اللي يجيك في النادي، وملتزم يذل للناس كلها الأكلة اللي تاكلها
يا سيدي أنت بتسوي الصَّح وممتاز وأحسنت، وأنت رائع
بس سيبني يا أخي
ويا أخي تدري من أن اللي قاعد تاكله هذا والله الشرايين عندك...
ياسيدي صح،وأنت ممتاز، وأتمنى لك دوام الصحة والعافية والموفقية
لكن ما هو وقته، صح كلامه بس يا أخي مو وقته
خلي نصيحتك ما تصير قلَّة أدب، بس
خلي دفاعك عن مبادئك...
أيش اللي حصل؟
ناظرني
شوف أنت أيش مسوي طيب
لا، يعني أتفق معك والله
يا أخي شُفت الوقيعة في الثُّقلاء
حتى أحد السلف يوم سألوه أيش أفضل شيء؟
قال: الوقيعة في الثُّقلاء
ممتع، لأن تستقعد ساعة كاملة تتكلم عن طائفة، وأنت تقدر تشوف
أنهم ثُقلاء
خلِّ الناس تعيش يا أخي
مو معنى أن خلّ أن النَّاس تعيش أن ما فيه أمر بالمعروف، ونهي عن المنكر
بس هذه كلها أمور تحتاج إلى فقه
تحتاج لأن أنت تكون تعرف مسائل الخلاف
وتعرف مراتب الإنكار، وعندك مُسكة علم، ومُسكة  عقل
وفوق هذا مُسكة أدب لحسة كذا بس حق أيش؟
لما تقدم المعلومة الصح تقدمها في غلاف ممتاز، بس
يجيك سلام أنه ماسك فكرة الحق، والباقي؟
تشرِّطني بالموس، وتقولي الحق بـ...
ياسيدي لا أبغاك أنت، ولا حقك شكرًا
وأنا ممكن لو راجعت نفسي بعدها بقول لك والله معاه حق
بس العفو منك ما أقدر أقبله بهذا...
أدعُ إلى سبيل ربك بالحكمة والموعظة الحسنة وجادلهم
آخر مرتبة المجادلة، احنا يا سيدي أنا عندي وقت للحكمة
والله أشُقَّك موس أعلِّم عليك، وأمشي أنتهينا
يا عمِّي إنجازات رصيد نهاية سنة
ما أستطيع عندي هدف أقفله
هذه الحالة المجتمعية السؤال جايك
الله يستر، أنتهت الفقرة
الصِّدق هذه الحالة إذا أقعد أتقفَّط لك ومدري أيش
من زمان ولا الحين هي جديدة،أقصد أن الواحد يتتبع
نفس البشرية هي، هي موجودة بس في النهاية...
« أخبار الحمقى والمغفلين» تحصِّل فيها يا كلام لابن الجوزي
كلام من هذول الناس اللي مولعين بالاستدراك
أخبار المتعلمين، موجود
لكن تويتر ما كان موجود، يعني تويتر خلّى اللي...
الله المستعان
تويتر يؤرّخ
في تاريخ الأفكار في العالم تاريخ علمي اجتماعي؟
قبل تويتر شيء، وبعد تويتر شيء
راح يجيوا كذا ناس يدرسوا الموضوع
حبيبي تويتر، ما يِلزمك إملاء ولا لغة ولا اسم ولا صورة ولا فكرة
ما يِلزمك ولا شيء عشان تشارك أحد الفلاسفة في نفس المساحة
قول أحد طالبك مرجع؟ لا تعطي مرجع، قول خرِّج
وأنت وأفضل متخصص في هذا الباب سواء
اسوء ما في الديمقراطية
والله العظيم
أسوأ ما أنتجته التقنية